oh wait I think I did it all right
all right thanks bud bye
guys in the chat can you hear us
you know what to do let us know let us
know if you can hear us
and then we will con you will get this
live stream going are we actually live
we're actually live right now we should
be
we can talk about the last of us we can
talk about The Last of Us
um how does it feel to hear your own
voice it's um it's unsettling because
you know I you know for my job I have to
hear my own stupid voice all the time so
I've gotten used to that part of it but
as I talk to have another smaller
version of me whispering in both my ears
at the same time yeah I um I'm a little
turned on to be honest but I'll let go
of that I'm just going to think about
baseball for the next hour is this what
people have been listening to all these
years
let's shout out some people in the chat
Eric how long do we have you here for
Buddy as long as you need me right we'll
be here all night if we have to figure
all night so let's shout some people out
let's see my Eric's son coaster obsessed
that's that's my kind of uh party guest
he asked me holy [__] Miko Kube
GoldenEye we're getting some questions
that we had okay so here's what happened
today is I was on a new Rockstar's break
room learning to get comfortable about a
new group of people and then suddenly uh
here now Eric
just that's a random day to be doing
this we had a nice little um drive down
the 101 we had a great heart to heart
chat together in a bit of Los Angeles
traffic that you know I don't miss
because I don't drive in San Francisco
my my wife takes the car to work I stay
at home with the dog and work from home
have you gotten used to saying my wife
hmm I still don't know I'm still not
used to it yeah I'm not used to it
either I love it it's so good to be able
to say because my fiance just feels like
incomplete right yeah why well why you
go from girlfriend to fiance and then to
wife and I what always struck me as odd
is the short has one syllable yeah
that's always the weird part to me yeah
yeah it's just it's short it feels like
there's something more coming but no
there's it's like solid it lands with a
thud yeah yeah all right like a marriage
good old ball and chain well she's great
she's great we talked in the car for a
while about life Mary he gave me
marriage advice because Eric is so much
more experience yeah he's got years I
got a couple months on this guy I've
seen some I've seen some stuff uh Lewis
Brown thank you for the super chess yeah
guys you you could we don't we're not
prepare you know how we live stream we
just we we go off of whatever you guys
want to ask in here or whatever Eric
wants to randomly bring up a Lewis Brown
it says oh my God what a crossover hello
from Scotland can you do a Scottish
accent no I can't do a Scotland accent
especially after that that was uh that
was impressive I can't follow that my
whole goal is just to impress Eric today
I'm already impressed
we've got a few super chats I put slow
mode on and this is not slowing down at
all right working guys if you were here
in the chat please go ahead and leave a
like as we slowly get back to feeling
normal and less disoriented But Eric
you're barely down here in Los Angeles
do you like it down here I love it I
love it we uh so Kelly and I for our
honeymoon at the beginning of the year
went to Costa Rica and just being in a
warmer climate because you know if
you've ever visited San Francisco it's
perennial fall so it which is a great
thing about it if you could just live in
somewhere in its Autumn Four Seasons
it's it's the best but you do miss the
warmer temperature I was in Los Angeles
for 12 years so just uh being in a
warmer place in Costa Rica you know
Kelly and I looked at each other we're
like we miss being a warm weather but
you know the warm weather in L.A it's
not like the warm weather in Costa Rica
Costa Rica the whole country smells like
flowers and everyone's very nice yeah la
you're in traffic most of the stuff
sounds like pollution and then the
city's on fire huh yeah so
um but I do I do miss the City of Austin
I really just miss the people down here
you know it's pretty much every time I
come down here it's for work and luckily
I get to run into guys like Greg Alba
especially at like uh premieres and
other kind of that's what area is always
hoping for remember the first time I met
you I was like he's so tall yeah you get
that a lot I do I do because when you
shoot your videos right you're like
mainly here yeah and so you don't look
you actually don't look tall I don't
yeah I I think uh the kind of content I
do my self-deprecation my slouching my
demeanor how much I hate myself everyone
just kind of Associates that with
shorter people but you know there's a
thing called the Napoleon complex people
and and that that's what gives people uh
undeserved confidence is when they got
something to compensate for sometimes
the self-deprecation goes so far it
sounds sincere
all right hello from Boston every time I
hear Boston I I just hear the word
[__] cocksucka so we can swear
because I was about to say we've seen
some [__] earlier I'm like I don't know
what your rules are well I figured we
need it since we're on the break room
and I'm like you can't swear it all on
the break room so I'm like we need to
watch ourselves I think you could say
[__] I just think it's just certain
things you can't say I love how you it
says two reaction goats from Jordan
ricotti Jordan that's nice you've become
a reactor as well I don't think I'm a
reaction goat I think you are a reaction
goad because you what you do really well
is uh just authentic kind of responses
but your authentic responses are in them
in themselves entertaining and fun to
watch yeah whereas I think like my most
authentic is when I'm just like a
I'm gonna have to pause that for 20
minutes
I don't know what that is I don't know
what's going on I don't know what that
character says and Disney didn't put
subtitles on this upload great but you
got the analysis and the the Deep dive
speaking of which Eric is that's one
thing we wanted to make sure we plugged
you got the Deep dive Channel and what's
going to be different about it than you
rock stars and we will get to every then
we're going to focus solely on the chat
yeah uh so the Deep dive launching
February 17th it's going to be a new
channel in the new rockstars Network
it's just gonna be me a lot of you are
asking oh you know you're going to some
of the other new rock stars host nope
nope they're not invited no they are
invited they can't go to hell well
here's the thing new Rockstar is going
to be the place where all the all the
hosts of the new rock stars family and
our friends like Greg can can come
together and nerd out on stuff but the
Deep dive you'll see when it goes live
the type of content that we're doing
there we're not going to do a lot of
reactive content it's really just going
to be my specific analysis into movies
that I really love and movies that you
really love so you have the first one
shot yet we have the first uh four
things can you tease one yeah I've I
think I've announced three of them so
far so the first video on the channel is
going to be a deep dive into everything
everywhere all at once recent Oscar
nominee uh and I'm so excited for people
to see what we came up with I'm working
with it's just really a two-person
operation there it's myself and Devin
Cleary who is an amazingly talented
editor who during new rock stars like
probably most Sergeant era from like
2018 through 2019 he was our lead editor
so if you look back at some of our
biggest videos whether it was our
breakdown of infinity war or The Dark
Knight trilogy Devon was really the
editor behind all of those so I was so
glad that he said yes when I asked him
Department partner with me on this but
he's currently working right now and
building just a beautiful layout for
this uh because we want it to visually
look different too sure I love making
the Easter egg breakdowns from new rock
stars I'm going to continue doing that
with the rest of the the crew over there
but specifically with the Deep dive we
wanted to look at movies differently we
want to look Beyond Easter eggs and just
cataloging exhaustively every Easter egg
and something is specifically focused on
just a fewer number of Easter eggs and
how they best reflect what is the the
filmmaker's hidden agenda with the movie
and because I don't know about you
because you talk a lot about Easter eggs
I realized at some point I don't know
what an Easter egg is anymore people are
like oh there's 207 Easter eggs in this
I'm like there's no freaking way there's
207 Easter eggs an episode of The Last
of Us are you kidding me but if I think
there are cases where things are Easter
eggs and there are times where they are
just like director choices sure sure
that to me are far more interesting than
whether a license plate refers to a
number of a comic book issue I think
it's way more interesting that uh in the
dark night uh Christopher Nolan put in
uh just on the edge of frame Two-Face
taking out one of the Thugs and getting
into the side of the car right with
Moroni uh and no one saw this when they
first watched the movie but you have to
see it on Blu-ray and you can only see
it in the side view mirror in his shot
of the car to me that is the most
interesting Easter egg and that's the
kind of stuff that it just shows that
the director cares for attentive View
viewers and that they they want
everything to make sense logically
um but with everything everywhere all at
once there is a I mean everyone seems to
be loving this movie I'm so glad to see
it get Awards attention and there's so
many ways that you can appreciate this
movie it's speaking to so many different
people but to me I think there is
something that a lot of the people who
are analyzing it whether it's critics or
other content creators are missing and
it is that there is a hidden love letter
in this movie from the director
co-director Daniel Quan to his mother
and it only is evident when he is asked
about this specifically in interviews
specifically the moment where Evelyn
says to Joy you look fat because she
doesn't know how to tell her that she
loves her and to me that opens up the
entire movie as uh the specific tale of
an immigrant mother trying to find her
way home yeah and aquana has talked
about how to get a point the Multiverse
and the Immigrant story have a lot of
overlaps because there's several
different Life Choices you could have
made and you're constantly reassessing
and judging the choices you have made
and that like blew open my mind and
that's the kind of analysis that I want
to do and I just haven't had the bandwid
with or the time to do this on the
neuroxers if I were to make all the new
rock stars hit the brakes and just join
me on that Journey we'd have to stop
doing all the other content that I love
that new rockstars does and it just felt
a little too indulgent and luckily the
company's been trying to Branch into a
network and we were able to just like
meet our our goals and I was able to say
like hey why don't you just let me try
this out I'll just do like one or two
videos a week yeah well we'll just have
one editor who just works on this
and uh and so far
it's been a great result I think this
everything everybody wants deep Dives
can be great we'll have a deep dive into
as well we're gonna look you back at the
Nine episodes of One Division okay okay
so I'm gonna revisit my Mephisto trauma
you guys hear that yeah and then I'm
gonna do a deep dive back into the six
episodes of Loki and really because I
think there's so many unanswered
questions from Loki uh and to me that
was the the best of Marvel phase four
and as we look ahead to Loki season two
into Ant-Man the lost quantumania I
think we have a lot of questions about
Kang and what the Dynasty's real agenda
is and there's a lot that we left on the
table for Loki that I mean despite all
the Easter eggs we found in it there's
just a lot there when it comes to what
exactly he remains plan was what was he
trying to do what was the threshold
moment all about no one can really
answer those questions but I think we
found a really good answer that's going
to make quantumania and King Dynasty
make a lot more sense and then since
we're launching the same day as
quantumania I'm going to do a live
stream breakdown holy [__] because a lot
of people are asking what goes on how do
you write a write breakdown and I'm like
I think there is a way I can live stream
and take questions so this is going to
be like a rehearsal for that right now
so we're gonna go live 9 A.M on uh on
February 17th it's gonna be a spoiler
discussion I'm gonna go through the
movie chronologically and just show
people what my process is breaking the
entire good screen or pulled up yeah at
that point we can't count on that wait
that has been the big coverage like me
and Devin are like how we are not gonna
have video access and we don't want to
pull any kind of like pirated bootleg
stuff for that so what we're going to do
is like assemble this is what we do this
part of our process of new rocks I think
you have a version of this too we
assemble what we call a string out which
is we go through every trailer every
scene that's been shown on Jimmy Kimmel
every promo still and we assemble a
chronological string out of the movie
and a lot of times with movies
especially with black panther wakanda
forever you can kind of get close to
having assets to cover everything yeah
so that that's that's what we use but I
want to show people how that string out
comes together because a lot of people
are like how did you find the footage of
this movie it's like well it's because
Marvel released it and there's always
yeah yeah
well that channel sounds like a big
waste of time
it's just kind of living in me and
Devin's brains right now I gotta say
um look Ty Frisk thank you for the Super
Chat saying best collab on the planet
and thank you for the Super Chat inside
I appreciate your existence Eric and
Greg
we appreciate your existence we
appreciate your existence the entire
time he was talking I did have an out of
body experience for a moment where I
found myself listening and nodding to
Eric and then my I wasn't actually
listening I was just like he's just in
my [__] home right now this is like
[__] weird I mean I have this weird
experiment he's just right here talking
to me right now that's these experience
I have every time I meet someone whose
name I am learning for the first time I
disassociate from myself I don't I
forget who they are yeah a second I piss
my pants it is a disassociation
experience like this is a weird trippy
like he's talking to me in front of me
in my home this is bizarre yeah well
it's such an honor to be here because
I'll say I um I was became aware of you
sometime in 2019 you guys were so nice
and reacted to one of our videos and I
was like these guys are amazing I love
these guys so I think I did a reaction
to you oh yeah I remember that I was
like people everyone was hitting me up
like you gotta react to this and we all
freaked out over that so that was a
great experience it was very exciting so
like I think you do such a good job
doing nice appreciative reactions to
things and you guys you know you do
really good analysis too here not enough
people hear it I think
we'll do a whole movie reaction I'm like
why are enough people sticking around
for the reviews we talked for like 40
minutes that's always my feeling instead
of just being grateful for the fact that
like a hundred thousand people watch
this video I'm always yeah I just go
down that path well what you guys do
really well and I and I wish that we saw
more of this in movie YouTube is just
appreciation and I think a lot of people
that's not valuable to them they want to
see uh criticism and and take down and
mockery yeah and I think that there is
uh even unappreciated benefit to just
recognizing the craft and the hard work
and I really think that comes from the
fact that you're a screenwriter I've
written screenplays before but I've
never sold or produced anything like you
have yeah so I think we know how hard it
is to write these things and to craft
these films yeah and I mean if you do a
one set visit you're like wow it takes
like 30 minutes to set up one shot and
yeah that's on like a good day you know
sometimes one shot can take like hours
to assemble so and I think new rock
stars especially when you've done that
that's you usually the takeaway that
I'll have in a breakdown is like you
know I did sometimes you'll cover
something that I don't even like and
then I'll watch it and I'll go but I
like it a little bit more now because of
what was pointing what's an example of
something that you didn't like that we
covered Venom let there be courage
yeah we did a breakdown of that yeah
that was that was a good example look
it's it's hard because like you know I
think people I like black widow black
widow yeah yeah that was another one you
know what's hard I think people assume
that I like all of these things and uh I
rarely do negative criticism I think if
you want to see me get Negative you got
to watch our inside Marvel after shows
because especially after the finale of a
Disney Plus show that's where you're
gonna find me in my saltiest generally
uh but so I will get real there and
especially now I'm doing live streams
it's gonna be hard for me to filter it
but like I get into this and the Deep
dive that we do for everything
everywhere at once because that movie
made me really think about my
relationship with my mom sure um and how
important it was uh at a certain
critical period of my life where she
would take me to movies specifically
take me to movies to escape from
bullying I was going through as a kid
and after school she could just see it
in my eyes like I just had a rough day
because I would never want to talk about
it instead of turning left to go home
she would turn right to go down to the
Orange Park 24 AMC uh Duval Jacksonville
in the chat let's go that's where we
would go and she'd take me to see a
movie and like that's how I could just
Escape into my own alternate life path
and that's why I'm So Into The
Multiverse but my mom would take me to
these movies that she had no interest in
scene and would never say anything bad
about it I could tell in her eyes if she
didn't like it she'd just be real quiet
I'm like Mom did you like that and she
would always say
you know it was interesting and I would
just try to get her to say something
negative I'm like admit it you hated it
and she goes no it was interesting and I
think that stayed with me and now as a
new Rockstar's host as a deep dive host
it's hard for me to hate on anything and
my mom doesn't come from the filmmaking
World sure
um but now as someone who does has gone
through the filmmaking world I see how
hard it is and if if a movie connects to
someone somewhere I never want to be the
guy who makes them feel stupid for
liking something right right and there's
so much of that on YouTube so I think
it's harder honestly to uh take a movie
that you know not everyone loved like
black widow and then point out some
really cool things in it that give
people a deeper appreciation for the
craft that is an impressive skill and I
think that's part of the it's cool to
see a channel be as successful that
mainly distributes positivity honestly
it's hard to find that because honestly
I mean I'm on my own private time I I
can I can enjoy a good drama video
I can enjoy a good like cynical video
from once in a while but um no I believe
in the practice of spreading the love
and sometimes you do it and people
question like there's something wrong
with there's one day I shared like a
bunch of instead of like 12 YouTube
videos of Just other YouTubers and I I
got a phone call from someone that day
going hey is everything okay
something must be wrong like it's such a
it's actually like an unnatural thing to
share spread positivity yeah in this
sphere well they think you're like
programmed that you're a shill and I I
right I think people forget that like
there is something to celebrate by the
fact that movies can bring us together
as opposed to tear us apart yeah you
know I think that's what makes movies
great is that we can find kind of common
reasons to love and enjoy something that
doesn't mean that we're brain dead
um it means that like oh we're
appreciative and we know how to stop and
smell the roses and and just appreciate
something now I've promised you to focus
on the chat 20 minutes ago so we got to
focus on the chat so let's yeah let's
see what people are let's go in here
sorry we've neglected YouTube neglect oh
no I love you oh my god I've lost I've
lost the spot okay oh we'll find it
we'll find it how far oh no I need to
get this uh I need to I'm gonna go
through the super chats here okay
because I missed it but now I'm gonna
bring this chat back Eric is I'll answer
one quick question and how tall are you
Eric I'm six two six two yeah that's an
impressive that's an impressive number
right there it's just a height
no that's I might be getting shorter now
I haven't I haven't measured my height
but I think at my Peak I was six two you
know once you get older you get shorter
so I might be like six one now how old
is your wife saying you're not not old
uh how tall is your wife I can tell you
tell me how old your wife is uh my my
wife is uh is shorter than me
um uh I think yeah I don't really know
how tall she is I think she's like five
ten five nine five eleven somewhere in
that range she's under six feet uh but
uh but I'm taller than her oh that's
great to know hold on what are you doing
over here I gotta verify my information
because YouTube is making me verify that
this is my account right now which is oh
wow it's perfect to happen during a live
stream get that uh yeah that because I
want to make sure we get to everyone in
super chats especially when you're here
because I know people are excited to see
you here I'm excited to be here it's so
nice to be able to chat with people in
in real time yeah I know it's great oh
wow we have so many super chats we gotta
yeah so I want to make sure we catch up
with some of them yeah we'll catch it
let's catch up let's catch up let's
catch up and then we'll don't worry we
will also be going through the actual
chat if you can we will too if you can't
Super Chat that's not I don't want you
to tell people to feel pressure that's
right it's very much appreciated but I
don't want you to feel pressured don't
feel pressure we appreciate it though
yeah we appreciate all you all y'all
being here yeah so great please leave a
like if you're here and thank you for
any comments that are happening right
now be subscribed to the real reject we
assume you've already subscribed if
you're seeing this right now but if
you're new to it if you just heard about
this from the new Rockstar's break room
or from my my Twitter subscribe to the
real rejects they're doing amazing work
here I love I love all your content
thank you buddy alrighty so we got to
get to Carlos the collector here in the
chat you see that I see Carlos he said
we'll have to go back down here that's
fine it's a journey we gotta do we got
panels have deeply rooted my love for
anything comic related thank you for
providing amazing breakdowns some of the
best reactions well Carlos thank you so
much that is what we what we aim to do
here so Tony Garza sent in his very
first Super Chat ever to us wow with a
moment of silence thank you Tony Garza
that's very much appreciated thank you
president of you Tony thank you bubba
Brock says um a great collaboration yeah
I've been doing all the heavy lifting
with all the talking here today yeah I
feel like uh everything you said about
you know actually on everything
everywhere at once saying that that
moment is very profound I have a
Filipino I'm half Filipino my mom is
Filipino and then both my brother and I
were like oh she reminds me oh I was
gonna [__] hate me
so much of my mom and then even my even
uh my wife when we watched it together
she was like I know who this woman is
that's okay but there is something like
culturally especially when it comes to
talking about weight that is such a that
happens a lot in like I think in Asian
culture where you talk where you focus
on body image sure
um Venom carne thank you for the Super
Chat Phantom Garnet um having played the
game do you think if there is a season
two of The Last of Us the heavy-handed
opinions would be the same as the second
games
um well I feel like the uh I mean how do
you I'm gonna be very curious have you
played the second game I haven't played
I played the first game I have not
played the second game I know what
happens in the second so you know we
will not spoil what happens in the
second game for you guys but I feel like
if you look at how they've adapted the
first season of The Last of Us they've
already infused a little bit more of
real world political commentary and I
think they would just kind of double
down when they do adapt the second
season I don't know if the right word
would be heavy-handed I feel like a lot
of times heavy-handed isn't open to
interpretation of how you receive it
however
um I I feel like whatever themes and
commentary were prevalent in the last of
us too my God you got to play that game
it's so good I know my favorite's been
on my list to do well here's the deal
yeah heavy-handed is you know it's in
the eye of the beholder right but I I do
think what Craig Mason is really good at
as a screenwriter is delivering uh
commentary in a pretty Artful and visual
way and it's within the story it's in
the story it's see I don't think I mean
there are parts of Chernobyl that are
appreaching like but they deserve to be
preachy something like what is the real
danger of Lies is the real theme of
Chernobyl and now I find this so
fascinating Have you listened to the
last of us at the podcast yeah
because he's talked he and Neil druckman
have talked about how love can be
dangerous how love can be toxic I've
never heard that every other movie is
about the power of love how love knows
no boundaries but this is the first time
they're dealing with Story how I love
how unconditional love can be really
dangerous and that kiss gesture in a
certain moment in episode two is a
destructive kiss true but in a way the
character is on the receiving end of
some intimacy that she was denied from
other people so I just find that
interesting as you continue to watch the
show let's keep an eye out for that so
and I think that's just an example if it
doesn't beat you over the head with the
theme and that theme is a pretty
subversive theme you know to say that
love can be destructive I think is a
pretty subversive thing to say and I
think I think if you when you play the
second game that that theme truly
carries over because a lot of yeah I
wish we could I will not dive into it
there's a lot more to say about but
thank you Venom Carney thank you for the
chat uh Bryce Burruss thank you for the
Super Chat my friend are either of you
going to play Jedi Survivor I'm a
thousand percent gonna play Jedi
Survivor I want to replay Jedi fall in
order first um but Jedi Survivor I I
mean the big talk is like will calcas
ever come into live action Star Wars
have you yourself tampered yet with uh
Jedi Fallen order I haven't played Jedi
I know what happened I've watched a
playthrough of Jedi fall in order I did
that before Kenobi just because but
here's the time here's the thing I don't
have a ton of time to game because I'm
constantly watching movies and
rewatching movies you got to get through
the [__] of the actual gameplay
I used to play so many games in high
school but I was in like the IB program
and I just had to stop gaming I had to
give it up because it was my entire life
and I was like falling behind in my
schoolwork so I literally swore it off
and I haven't looked back but like I've
always wanted to get back into it I just
know it will take over my life when when
I don't say if
it does I've lost so much sleep and time
just to actual gaming that and now I
only play games and I'm like like when
God of Wars like when I when I know a
trailer is coming back I'm like all
right I gotta I gotta replay this I
gotta I gotta go through it again
um resident nerd man thank you for the
super chats man
um he says MCU who Marvel movies what ah
more of a GCU guy the goat Cinematic
Universe starring Eric and Greg well
thanks man have you gone to another
person's live stream thank you by the
way I've never been on an I don't know
oh [__] but I'm broken
I've been on new rock stars breakthrough
before I'm trying to think I want to say
I've been on someone else's you know
what I used to do is After Buzz TV oh
yes everybody I think that's live but
that's a live podcast yeah I think it's
a little bit different it's different
this is different we're talking with you
guys
um Lewis Brown great accent unless we
must Scottish action I was on a zoom
with Eric at the start of the pandemic
on new Rockstar's Discord and he
couldn't enter stand my accent then I
think I remember you it's good racist
that might have been for my birthday or
something like that we had a Discord uh
or maybe we just checked in with people
you know I think we used to do some
watch alongs and stuff but I appreciate
your support because back then I think
you could only get on a Discord by being
a patriot so I really appreciate you man
thank you Lewis uh Aiden Corey thank you
what's AUD do you know where that is you
know what that currency is I don't know
that current Australian dollars that
makes a lot of sense that's why you're
the man
I don't know hey guys predictions of
guns upcoming DC slate we were just
talking about this over on uh the new
rockstars live stream
um I have one thing that I feel like one
thing that I I think he would actually
be attempting to do that I didn't bring
up in the break room
I wanted to reserve the good stuff right
here
I didn't bring it up in the break room
and it wasn't until I read the thread
that James Gunn put out about like not
wanting multiple universes right off the
bat and the fact that Batman 2 is
happening and I know he's praised Matt
Reeves work before any of this
announcement and what kind of filmmaker
he is I feel like he is going to attempt
to at least persuade in some way Matt
Reeves to let Batman his Batman be the
Batman of the DC Universe you should you
should it was such a good Batman like I
think that movie it there maybe should
have been some scenes that were trimmed
down it might have been a little long
but like I love that movie so much yeah
it was almost a Flawless movie I think
the score I think it like it definitely
should have been nominated for score and
for cinematography cinematography snub
is the biggest it's a weird one that was
a weird one but they're they're I think
it's at the Hollywood Bowl they're doing
a live Orchestra with the music for the
movie yeah I gotta go check that out
that sounds fun yeah so you have one
prediction of the gun slate one out of
the few he said he might reveal what's
do you have one thing he might
um one come on give us
good I think he's gotta he's gonna cast
a new Superman but he wouldn't announce
that I he might I think he should I
think he will just right away just like
yeah everyone shut up about Henry Cavill
here's I think it's gonna be someone we
know and love and it would be undeniable
to show some love to that person Finn
wolfhard
huh I said everyone will know
[Laughter]
oh it's positive
stranger things I say Mike from stranger
things let's get it going or Timothy
Shelby why are you going thin to win man
I desire to feel like they were just I
want a beefy boy I want to see him bulk
up I want to see Finn wolfhardt oh we
don't body shame here no let's do it uh
Stacy's grape soda thank you for the
Super Chat hey this is nice lots of love
from Turkey boys thank you Stacy's grape
soda it's very Stacy's grape soda oh my
God okay we do this and then we bring
back the chat and I think we're caught
up on the on the chat are we yeah yeah
after we do oh did we cycle back around
yeah yeah uh Carlos The Collector thank
you Carlos The Collector he says Carlos
your channels have deeply rooted my love
for anything comic related uh thank you
for providing amazing breakdowns and
some of the best reactions thanks man
thank you so much thank you for watching
do you have a breakdown that you're like
that's my favorite one if there's one
that you feel like you could point to
and go I'm the most proud of that one I
mean the Deep dive I'm doing everything
everywhere all at once it's my favorite
thing I've ever made really yeah I mean
I'm biased by recency
um but before that historically at new
rockstars I really really like the
breakdown I did of The Dark Knight
um I've seen that it's from The Joker
and the thumbnail yeah good good thing
that's specifically what I liked about
it it's not like Easter eggs because I
think people forget Nolan's movies don't
really have Easter eggs in the way that
most people think of Easter eggs but
they do have a really great attention to
detail in craftsmanship
um and uh I feel like the same way about
their Matrix breakdown yeah that's up
there too both Devin uh edited that one
and the uh and The Dark Knight ones
um with with the team you didn't do them
all by himself but he was really leading
the effort there
um but the uh we had some really great
analysis in that Dark Knight breakdown
into Game Theory
um like you know the Pirate game the
shrinking pie game we're looking being
able to look at logic because that's one
thing I love about the Joker in that
movie is he's like really clever in the
way that he tortures people he's the
prisoner's dilemma on the two fairies
right like so he's able to like he's
almost like an economist that's part of
like the mystery of the character is
like yeah he seems to be like um a past
Soldier some people were saying he's a
CIA interrogator in the past I think the
guy was like a Unabomber Ted Kaczynski
Economist that that's what I think was
his history I I remember that breakdown
pretty well that was I think I'm saying
like twice thank you actually a fan oh
[__] Eric listen some [__] you've done
man I don't need always a camera pointed
at me to look at a new rock stars video
hey I know how to do it man all right oh
TJ Perry I went to school with this guy
Charles what up guys if you could pick
anyone to play in live action The Last
of Us part one and part two who would
you pick like us personally to play hmm
I mean for me it would have been bill
but Nick offerman's the best bill yeah
that happened so it hasn't aired yet
yeah so well the trailer's out there I
didn't spoil anything we know he's
playing he's playing the character he he
doesn't I've seen I've just as of now
seen episode three it's great uh I I
think I think uh I would love to play uh
Abby in The Last of Us Part Two I think
they should go against type okay and let
a Italian Filipino man play Abby
everyone's favorite character from the
game I think I can do it I think I think
he could really do heavy adjusted I
guess you're happiest John I could
probably
you cowards night I've always wanted to
be liked and I feel like I would finally
get that approval from the public yeah
that'll fix everything
um Duncan McDonald thank you so much
we're back here you're in the chats
pickle brick nice call
oh yeah yeah oh Rick and Morty's a great
reputation at the moment right now I'm
glad we're I think Rick and Morty has a
has a great reputation some of the
people who worked on Rick and Morty
going through some trouble this stream
is all I need hello from New Zealand new
zeit can you do a New Zealand accent I
here's what I can do I can start talking
like psycho TT but then it goes away
real fast can we get a preview yes uh is
gold the gold which is going to be in
this movie but I'm going to quickly make
all the cool things about the character
not part of the movie slightly turned
into Obi-Wan Kenobi a little bit halfway
through
and then I quickly looked like an
[__] because like I can't really do a
good impression of him so I thought it
was wonderful it was very very
impressive uh Pablo Ruiz nice to see you
back here buddy hey man see ya Dia kite
your contents are both worth a lot Big
Love Bros thanks bud thanks thanks you
thank you dance Productions when do you
think James Gunn will announce the DC
use like yeah when the [__] is he gonna
announce I think [__] next five days you
think like 31st at like 11 30 p.m
see I was gonna say tomorrow
well here's the deal here's the secret
so in secret Insight we're going to give
you about how Hollywood news Cycles work
okay okay let's hear it okay so normally
you get breaking news that the studios
feel positive about on Monday or Tuesday
yes because they want it to dominate the
news cycle for a week when there's
controversial news that comes out they
wait till a Friday why because they know
those damn reporters who work for The
Hollywood Reporter deadline all have
kids that they want to spend time with
on the weekend so they're less likely to
spend the weekend writing articles and
tweeting about it and asking for
interviews so if it's news that he
thinks may be controversial undoubtedly
might be yeah we might see it tomorrow
oh [__] that's a great Theory
when you see Studios like announce
layoffs or things like that or announce
cancellations most of the time that news
comes on a Thursday or Friday you could
have made a video about that and we will
yeah
there it is Hello from Washington hi
who's gonna watch the Winnie Pooh Winnie
the Pooh blood and honey it's what do
you think about these uh it's a side
question non-comic related what do you
think about all these uh remakes that
they're doing they're like the Bambi
horror remake uh the the just the Grinch
one that came out uh Winnie the Pooh
blood and hot I like it because Winnie
the Pooh is now in the uh public domain
so they can kind of have fun with it
look I'm someone who likes Winnie the
Pooh for what Winnie the Pooh was and
like the kind of guy who would yeah
although I didn't see the Ewan McGregor
one as bad as what you'd expect okay
well I liked it I'm acting like it was a
terrible experience I'd like the movie
yeah I didn't say it it's another movie
where Disney's message is uh you know uh
don't be corporate and be uh be with
your family that matters more than money
but this is being produced by a Disney
kid that's always the ironic part about
it to me I would say I like it when
things get I don't mind when things get
remade but I what I really like is when
they find like the original essence of
what the Creator intended for it so when
they when they bastardize it or turn
into something dark it's like well then
why not just make cocaine bear and they
do they're now making cocaine bear great
awesome I'm super excited for cocaine
here I'm more excited for original
content that takes just extreme Concepts
and blows them out of proportion that's
why I was I'm so happy about the
reception everything ever all at once is
getting because that's a movie that
shouldn't be so attainable to a mass
audience right but it is it totally is
yeah it's it's a better Multiverse movie
that goes to the fur the far reaches of
the Multiverse but feels so intimate and
personal at the same time because it was
interesting I watched Multiverse Madness
first and I really enjoy you're sitting
right behind me yeah that's right
scratching the pen and you're just like
stop it I'm trying to watch the movie
I'm right really loud
um he doesn't like jot down like a
madman just like Doc Brown yeah
um and so I watched it first and and uh
everyone around me who did not like
Multiverse of Madness would always go
yeah but have you seen everything in
your room once that that's what it
should have been like so I hadn't seen
it and then I understood the opinion
then of why Multiverse Madness went down
a lot for people see after I think
Multiverse of Madness would have been a
better movie if it was called Doctor
Strange versus Scarlet Witch or the
Scarlet Witch and the Multiverse of
Madness or take the word madness out of
the title because like as a movie about
the Scarlet Witch having a really bad
day I think it's great Sam Ramey does
the Scarlet Witch story I think as as
those parts of the movie are the best
parts of it it's when it tries to be a
Multiverse movie it it misses the mark
yeah Illuminati portrayal overall was
alive but I like I like the Illuminati
Slaughter I think a whole sequence of
introducing our favorite fan casted
versions of these characters and having
want to slaughter them I think was a
brilliant Choice yeah but I think as a
movie that wants to explore more of the
Multiverse like I kind of wanted to live
in a38 a bit more and not have it
presented as just the jokiest part of
Rick and Morty yeah what I think like
they could have still had what it lacked
in the script for me was there was a
lack of true distinct personality for
all the people in the Illuminati they
were kind of just like it was all one
character having a single monologue but
yeah and if you're gonna put them like
all their dialogue could have been
interchangeable between any of them
where I I really thought like in order
to make this work you could have just so
they all just got stoic dialogue is what
they were all given and I thought they
could have really enhanced it by just
make each one have a distinct
personality have them debate have the
bicker you know uh I think the one
distinct moment we got was Xavier saying
just because someone Falls and loses
their way
which was a line from another movie yeah
they quote another line for another
movie that was the one time I was like
oh these people are human beings but I
thought it like before I saw everything
everywhere I thought like it it kind of
did live up to the madness on a first
viewing on the second viewing I was like
I guess not yeah everything every all at
once no no uh Doctor Strange oh Doctor
Strange yeah the first time I was like
oh cool we're going together
like and I think that's the only
expectation a movie is obligated to live
up to is your first viewing in a movie
theater sure now I am the kind of person
who loves the movie more the second time
General but the first time I'm watching
I'm always just so overwhelmed by it and
I'm just not even taking it all in I
just I'm looking at the spectacle of it
and I'm so easily won over or so easily
disappointed uh but every time I watch a
movie a second time with like a
different person or by myself that's
when I'm really understanding what the
movie is yes so maybe I'm full of [__]
every movie needs to be seen twice
that's all I understand it but I'm
saying as a filmmaker they only need to
win us over that first time true true
that's true
are you having fun I'm having a blast
this is great all right I asked that in
any conversation in life oh am I having
fun in the middle of any hangout like
are you having fun oh yeah are you
having fun with me
most of the time I'm super uncomfortable
and like I hit like kind of a a
countdown in my head like like you know
how Sonic and the Sonic games like the
music speeds up and you're trying to
catch the bubbles that's how I am in
every conversation generally I'm like
I'm disappointing them they hate me they
judge me right now I'm really bad at
talking to them I didn't finish that
sentence correctly so you do get like a
social anxiety as well oh yeah because I
have that all the time yeah the first
time I met you I was like I feel like
this guy [__] hates me like that was
that was always I'm sorry I made you
feel that way I mean I generally feel
that way even the whole time on break
room I'm like I am botching this oh you
were great with him on the break room he
was fantastic when the camera wasn't on
us he Eric turned him he's like you're
doing great
that was a genuine and then it went to
me going is this because you can tell
like I don't feel like I'm doing a good
job all I did is I noticed that we
weren't on
Ben Enoch you should go on the H3
podcast I should be and thank you for
the Super Chat you should we would go if
we were invited I mean I think you'd be
very much desired there the iron lamb
thank you for the Super Chat best
YouTube collab yet wow wow it's a lot to
live the best thank you I think I've
seen maybe some slightly you could do
better yeah I'll step up my game
um are you planning on doing a breakdown
on DC spin-offs on newnan's what's
Newton's
we're not planning on doing that
correctly that they know of but if the
show takes off we'll take a look at it
plot twist Voss isn't there he's in
front of a green screen we don't use
green screen we use blue blue screens
that's how I was able to put him in the
thumbnail today hey that's something
that I can I can share for the Deep dive
so uh we use the blue dungeon background
yes it was supposed to be keyed out in
our videos back in the olden days but we
just didn't do that so we became the
video it became a background that's now
we're actually keying me into a
different space so you see me on the
Deep dive I will not be in the blue
dungeon anymore I will be in a different
space that's funny yeah I almost texted
you like can you can you send me a photo
I'm like wait a minute he's in front of
a blue screen
just find a photo of him in one of the
videos and I got this
um you and me both uh Easter egg used to
be hard but now Easter eggs are handed
on a silver plate I do miss kind of the
days when Easter eggs were a little bit
uh
now now it feels like sometimes it's
sort of a perfunctory right that's what
I'm saying yeah I don't think anyone
really knows what an Easter egg is
anymore and you know I think it's
because there's a lot of blogs I don't
think this is YouTube's fault I think
this is buzzfeed's fault I think it's
all the blogs that are out there that is
that that are saying here are a bunch of
Easter eggs and then none of the things
in the article are Easter eggs it's like
oh yes I I know that Black Adam came
from the comics that's not an Easter egg
despite you're putting a one in front of
it
um so yeah I think we've uh We've
distorted what the intent of an Easter
egg should be it should be hard to find
it should be hard to find and really
cool when you do find it there should be
some kind of satisfaction you get out of
it yeah uh like I think the fact that
you know people were saying there were
no Easter eggs in Andor it's like no
there just weren't you know there wasn't
a freaking CAD Bane cameo in Andor that
CAD Baines Cameo and book above it was
not an Easter egg we all obviously saw
it was CAD Bane yeah but it doesn't
count but they were straight up there
were Easter eggs there but I remember it
was 10 is Gilroy Gill Tony Gilroy Gilroy
and Gilroy he did say like there's no
Easter eggs here
so yeah that's that's your point is that
like oh maybe they don't even know the
term has no meaning anymore so I'm just
I'm just so can we retire the word the
term Easter eggs stupid good for SEO you
know well now though now we got a weird
Christian holiday that's among the most
used words in our SEO language it says
true I never looked at it that way it
doesn't make any sense the resurrection
of Christ is a prevalent everywhere now
yeah I mean look I I just think it's I I
really really love Easter eggs when they
are truly they have to be intentional by
the Creator let's be clear that someone
put it there it can't just be like hey
her dress is red in this shot red in
every movie means a character is mad or
evil it's like no that's not where red
mint and turning red that's not what red
meant in Schindler's List you're just
you don't know how to do media analysis
if you think that uh but I'm just saying
like you can't just like say oh that
means this so then everything equals
everything then if that's the case so I
think it has to be intentional and my
favorite example is in Andor the very
first minute of Andor andor's walk into
that brothel and he's passing by all
these sex workers who are in their weird
little Bubbles and they're like hey yeah
have sex with me in the background in
here
[Music]
oh God I'm like I know I've heard that
sound before and it is the sound of the
maternity Droid who delivers Luke and
Leia comforting oh yes they pulled the
sound of a maternity Droid comforting a
pregnant woman giving birth and to
someone in the Star Wars universe that
is their Kink and I think that is the
coolest freaking Easter egg I don't know
if Tony Gilroy is aware of it may just
spin Pablo Hidalgo threw it in there
because he thinks it's hilarious but I
love that to someone they want to go get
with someone and the sound they hear to
get off is
that's a cool Easter egg that is a cool
Easter egg that's a good point what a
fat this should be I think that could be
a good Deep dive topic I think so in
fact that was something that I pitched
like just a true redefinition of what is
an Easter egg and looking at the history
reviews I mean the first Easter egg
Ready Player One dug into that first
gamer Easter egg of just wanting the
artist want to give themselves credit
and hiding it into the code of the
secret room which I think is really cool
that that is the idea it has to be
someone who's like a Creator who's
working on it is hiding some kind of
deeper significance or some deeper
meaning that's important to them and
putting their stamp on it putting their
signature into something [__] love
that that's sexy
that's gonna be my new sex noise
yeah my wife's just gonna be like what
the hell are you doing but why is it
working
to turn on though right
you all should smash can't wipes won't
let us we dreaded by them earlier uh
sanitiki have you seen the menu what do
you think got a reaction up on this
channel I loved it watch it watch it we
um Jessica Clements at new rockstars did
a short about a deleted scene with them
with the food critic oh on on the
channel it's it's really really
fascinating you should check it out and
I think new rockstars may be doing a
breakdown breakdown we should have done
one weeks ago we weren't really sure but
um I really like the menu and I've I had
never done the tasty menu experience
until my honeymoon Kelly and I splurge
because honeymoon we did a tasty menu in
Costa Rica it's the best food experience
I've had in my life was it like the menu
no no no no no it was far more
accessible it was just kind of simple
food that uh well not simple food it was
really complex and just delicious but
like being in San Francisco there's a
lot of like Foodies and gastro tourists
yeah yeah and like you can really get
lost in that world uh I mean people will
like go to other countries just to go to
these places and so I've just in the
past years started to be exposed to that
I'm not doing it myself but I have
friends who do so it's just a
fascinating commentary on that entire
subsection because there's a lot of
toxicity and problematic things um like
the way those workers are treated how
little they're paid how much they're
abused watch the bear I think the bear
is what got me into it in the bear I
haven't seen the bear check out the bear
the bear um Jeremy Allen White
um on FX I believe uh it's a guy who was
from that world who basically had a
breakdown had to leave that world due to
a family crisis and had to take over the
old Family Restaurant which is a Chicago
sandwich shop got it got it got it and
so he's trying to apply his experience
and try his experience with fine dining
but just apply it to something that a
lot of people doesn't don't consider
very complex but uh fine dining training
can apply to anything that you're making
even a simple hamburger as we know from
the menu so
um yeah watch the bear and uh it's it's
great and he obviously suffered a lot of
emotional abuse and uh from his life
yeah
well damn
watch I want to know what you ate
it's the only meal I've had where I
remember everything because I oh yeah
yeah actually every night every year you
might get a question by the cook later
on in a couple years yeah it was so good
I I it's kind of a secret thing if you
ever go to it they keep the menu a
secret they're just like trusted really
and that's how a lot of these tasty mini
places are like in the movie The Menu he
doesn't tell you obviously
The Mystery of the movie I I think
Horror's getting's like I I that's
something that we've been doing a little
bit more on the real rejects trying to
cover more horror recently especially
with with the term elevated horror which
I feel like is kind of an insult
um was the Evil Dead not elevated that's
what I mean it slights it uh like
Exorcist would would be considered
elevated is that one Awards I guess it's
a genre like there's just genres of
horror and I think that with the rise of
social commentary horror I think horror
has been like so much more interesting
now to me but I also think good horror
has always been social of course of
course Rosemary's Baby which is
unfortunate considering the director of
Rosemary's Baby yeah I am it is I think
it's one of the best uh case studies in
a gaslighting and rape culture is
Rosemary's Baby and it came out in 1968.
well it's I mean the horror itself is
it's great that you can have an
experience of fear in a way that is the
most vicarious fear living experience
Millions yet you can have such deeper
meanings and that of intense emotion
like when I write I tend to write it
like even if I'm not writing a horror
thing I like to have a little bit of
horror infused and I feel like some of
the best movies do like Jurassic Park is
is a horror movie sure you know I think
it's more people I think the yeah the
premise of it is it's like Jaws jaws is
a horror movie you know but I think like
Swan is like Black Swan that's like a
horror I mean one of my favorite things
to look at is really scary scenes in
movies that are not at all horror films
like Lord of the Rings when Bilbo goes
yeah I love that in in Spider-Man I mean
Sam rainey's a horror director but so
he'll always try to put jump scares in
his movies but when randomly Green
Goblin just goes yeah
no that Sam raymie always infuses it
Lord of the Rings is great pool because
yeah Peter Jackson was a horror director
too yeah yeah so that you know he was
supposed to do the last Nightmare on Elm
Street movie really and then they did
New Nightmare instead yeah wow he had a
whole pitch for it it was great and then
it just got released recently raccoon
shampoo I haven't seen your name in
forever I may have asked this before
thank you for the Super Chat can't
remember but what do you think about
making the DCU Batman into a TV series
instead of a movie
oh interesting I mean guns does excel in
the television realm but I think you can
do
um
more different kinds of stories
obviously on the TV series
um but I think it needs to be a limited
run series like just kind of an
open-ended series it's going to start
seeing diminishing returns after a while
24 episodes
45 minutes long yeah it's also less
profitable I would imagine yeah right I
don't know I don't know how much how I
don't run a studio or run a network so I
don't really know what the profit is but
was Game of Thrones in a hole more
profitable to HBO or to the Warner
Network than like your average Warner
movie hit that makes a lot of oh that's
a fascinating question I would say the
series is probably more at least Game of
Thrones was because it really put HBO
subscriptions on the map for like six
years well I think a series with a
dedicated fan base tends to have a
stronger merchandise uh profit than um
than a solo movie picture does too
because the fan base for a show can be
much stronger much more communal film
it's trying to do different things but I
think like the big money in Hollywood is
in movies of course it's not in
television generally I would love to see
a Batman show though I would I don't
think they'll do it but man it would be
cool to see a Batman series like a lot
of people still consider anime the
Batman anime series like the Pinnacle of
Batman and like are they getting into
something you hear the cats I hear some
wrestling I hear cats and I'm like oh my
God no don't be doing anything better
what do you think get me in trouble you
wouldn't see a Batman TV show but I
would see a family movie but I think of
live I mean it would be very [__]
expensive but now with television like
you're looking at the last of us I'm
like you could do it yeah okay but the
last of us is gonna be a limited run and
The Last of Us also isn't like a
superhero story like just all the stunts
that you would need to make a Batman
story pay off all the car chases the
explosions using a city it'd have to be
a massive massive budget TV show unless
you kept it very very hyper focused on
just like real
work yeah yeah you could yeah you could
I would just say like do a good
detective story but don't make it a
Batman story like the Batman could do a
different original one the Batman could
have been a show but that finale is so
big yeah that that part I'm like I don't
know you could do that I just think
there are examples there's like good
audio
um podcast stories that were a Batman
detective stories there's great games
you can do there like there's Batman the
anime series just rewatch yeah we watch
Batman Beyond like I don't need a Batman
like just keep building out this Robert
Pattinson thing I'm enjoying this ride
yeah you know
all right I agree great collab on screen
right now live that's great to hear and
no crypto thank you
Tony Garza thank you for the Super Chat
you two are my heroes thank you for what
you do us two I like when I'm on the
same same level as Eric was that makes
me feel good I feel like we're on the
same level totally earned it here
um there oh thank you everything
everyone all at once having a nice
discussion no movie made me ball is like
I did a reaction for it and I've never
uncontrollably sobbed like I have where
I'm like it got to the point where like
this is embarrassing there is a key like
that's that's kind of the thing about
when you're doing reactions is the whole
whole purpose is to be vulnerable when
you're on camera whether that's share
your excitement share your love or cry
if you feel like crying
um but yeah they did get to the point on
my everything I roll it once more I'm
like this is embarrassing for me to
watch it's just bawling non-stop I
watched it in the theater with my now
wife we weren't married yet but and then
I watched it on a plane recently just to
re-watch and I'd rewatched it before
that I've seen it probably a total four
times five times
um but there's always two scenes that
every time making great but I think each
time I watch it it's more likely to make
me cry and it's oh one is the shot where
kihui Kwan in when he's like an
alternate universe as like the the rich
guy says like and you might know this
now as a married man he's like I would
have loved just in another life just
doing lunch oh [__] yeah my eyes are
watered
and like for those of you I hope those
of you it's not doesn't have to be
through marriage but I'm just saying
like try to find that person for you who
you just are enthralled to do laundry
and taxes with that's how I feel yeah
that's what I feel I love doing laundry
with Kelly I love just cocaine I love
just doing dishes show wash I'll clean
I'll clean she'll wash I love just doing
chores with her I love doing mundane
shopping with her like that's that is
what the good stuff is in life yeah
sometimes when you go to the store and
it's just better when she's there with
me Kelly Kelly
performing that's where she goes all the
time
and uh yeah but my favorite thing in the
world is just to watch like what what do
you watch with it oh yeah I never got a
lot thank you guys for everything in the
chat this means the world
um and uh but I do have to ask Eric what
is the what is a show that you watch
with your wife that I assume is not like
some comic because everything a lot of
what I like I watch Love is Blind yeah
we watch The Challenge MTV's The
Challenge all right because you know
Johnny Bananas CT CT where is there any
bananas backpack yeah we watched that
um now we say we watched that Kelly has
it on I'm tuning in pretending like I
don't care really playing wingspan the
game on my iPad just kind of unwinding
from a day of making movie analysis and
I'll look up and be like
who does CT think he's fully so we watch
that and then we watch Great British
baking show oh um yeah or bake off if
you're in in the UK have you seen nailed
it no the Netflix show nailed it no it's
a baking show oh you gotta watch that
yeah yeah it's actually it's really
funny nailed it it was huge for a while
oh we gotta check it out I don't know
how to explain it efficiently is that
what you watched with your message I
used to I'm actually showing her
breaking bad right now oh fun just got
to the final episode of season three
she's never seen it I was trying to
convince her for years to watch it see
we did that when we first started dating
we re-watched breaking out on Netflix
um now we we wanted to we had also done
it with Mad Men and we want to go back
and re-watch Mad Men but now you can
only find it somewhere like through
Amazon you have to watch commercials the
commercials are so damn long so we're
like damn no we're gonna give it up
we're not gonna We're not gonna sit
through the commercials are you kidding
me speaking of which I'm gonna run a
mid-roll right now okay here we go
do wish she had a boner that never ever
went away
one day coyan and Eric will uh see each
other in person can we call Koi
just see coin that guy's great you guys
have never shared the camera together we
haven't we have it it's like we might be
the same person that would be instant
that would be just one of us suddenly
gets really hits I would love it comes
and slightly more knowledgeable about uh
about a lot of things just more likable
in general and then it reverts to slime
and that's who I am
uh that I would love to say I think that
could break the internet you and coin
the same video together we should uh
yeah there's almost a Mota awesome
there's almost a year gap between the
Marvels and the next MCU movie I don't
feel like the Marvel's getting enough
love I did like your interview you did
with uh this is like my favorite thing
that I did in 2022 other than getting
married how did that happen how did that
go about was that you're doing she
reached out to us no [__] so we had done
some I think it was the first time we'd
ever gotten junket interviews because
you know you can get in that game
sometimes where they'll they'll put you
on a list of like 40 different Outlets
yeah you get to just wait in the waiting
you wait in the zoom room for hours and
then you interview someone who's like
eighth build on it or something yeah
um but we love doing that we want to do
more of it
we will do all of it we won't say no to
any of it but anyway we were doing that
from his uh from his Marvel
and Iman villani watched new rockstars I
bet she watches real rejects too she
watches all of it she's so positive
about her show yeah so I think she
watches a lot of this stuff she's on the
Marvel Studios spoilers subreddit she's
everywhere she's she's big true nerd of
this stuff she's got her notebook and
it's filled with like questions of
Marvel Studios lore so um she watched
new rock stars and uh when we did our
first trailer reaction or breakdown I
got like message the guy who plays the
older brother is uh was on a sketch team
at the UCB Theater in LA with a friend
of ours and he said hey so we have this
Mutual Facebook friend he reached out
he's like hey so everyone on the Ms
Marvel cast watched your breakdown in
love including in Iman and then he's
like iman's not on social media as soon
as she got cast and Marvel stuff they're
like don't go into it yeah yeah yeah
let's take down your Twitter take down
your Instagram take it all down so you
can't find her anywhere on Twitter but
she probably has some lurker accounts
would be my guess and uh and so she
watched our breakdown as a huge fan of
it and so after we had done the junket
interviews uh the Disney press person
reached out and said hey Iman is
interested in doing it
Marvel came out I'm like whenever she
wants to yeah we will do it could be
years from now but we'll put it on the
books and so she was so so kind
um and uh we had this great interview
and you know the best interviews I
assume you've done a lot of interviews
and that's how I feel right now you let
go of whatever plan you had going into
it you just talk yeah and uh and that's
how I felt with Iman I had a list of
questions but like she we just started
just talking about real CU trivia after
a bit and that's hard to find VIA Zoom
most of the time it's hard to zoom
especially leave a like if you're here
by the way yeah leave a like leave a
subscribe yeah well leave a watch I do I
love you I don't wonder how you feel
about this I I think yeah we got some
good questions here we got to get some
yeah um I think that uh uh Aman villani
is one of the most underappreciated
casting choices
like she is that character I like Beyond
just like a month alone he's playing
herself that's not what I'm saying it's
like she's one of those people that
right when you meet that character you
just see and feel and she's lived it's a
full three-dimensional performance from
beginning to end and I feel like she
does not get enough credit for being one
of the most apt best casting choices
ever especially for younger characters
they don't really get it right
um and I think they really did get away
with with Iman I think she inhabits the
role of Kamala Khan and it's not an easy
role to play because so much of the
character's likability is just on their
personality yeah and she pulls it off
she like but she brings the depth too
without it without weighing too much
into the depth like like being gravity
toss heavy all the time yeah like she's
not trying to oversell the drama no
she's not she's a but the character of
kamalakon is a fan yeah exactly and I
think they made such a smart choice
casting Iman villani because she is a
true fan of the Marvel movies and you
can see that in her work and yeah I
don't it's not easy to play yourself as
soon as you get on a set in front of
with cameras like you can't just beat
Charming immediately it's awkward it's
an unnatural experience so to be able to
like have that confidence and to play
that character naturally is like a real
gift and a real talent and like there's
I mean Michael kind is not playing
characters he is playing himself but I
love him and I think he's an amazing
actor because he makes that charming and
yes interesting every time he's in a
scene he takes it over completely agree
I love I love what Mom bolani's work
especially though I think she deserves
more credit she's the main reason I'm
excited for the Marvels
um who is ravana to be to he who remains
is King already love her
I think he does I think they used to be
in a relationship and she doesn't
remember it anymore and I think it's an
Eternal Sunshine thing hey watch our
Loki Deep dive I'm gonna get into all
that stuff I think
the term for all time always is for how
long Kang will love ravana
um all right nice to hear
uh okay yeah all right moving on to this
Disneyland question America
do you remember people do how often do
you get recognized when you go out in
public is it a very always sometimes uh
most of the time people just like get
out of the way your dog you're talking
about move please
um but sometimes I mean when we go when
we go to the movies when we go to Disney
yeah we're gonna meet more because
that's you know the fans are so or not
fans just fans of these things so I
would love to just we should just go
around in public together and then count
who gets recognized more no no we're not
doing that I'm sure you would win
but yeah Lane I see your your comment it
was uh really nice to meet you as well
at Disneyland we we're dying to go back
to check it out sometime in the new year
but um we're in the new year now again
I'm in December but yeah yeah when we
were last at Disneyland
um Kelly started to keep score I was
like why are you keeping scorching like
I'm just gonna keep score and then and
she but she was wearing a Luca shirt
because my wife works for Pixar and she
had worked on the movie Luca so she was
accounting to keep score how many people
stop her for her shirt because there's a
lot of Luca fans who are at Disney World
too so or Disneyland said she was
keeping track and then she kind of lost
track for her oh there you go that's a
little humble braggler well you walked
through Avengers campus there's just a
lot of fans out there it's nice to meet
I think I was wearing this shirt too
yeah it's the most identifiable part
um Eric what happened to Wookie leaks a
new rock stars it's coming back it's
coming back for the Mandalorian for sure
and I I think a lot of you guys have
wanted us to do it for a bad batch it'd
be really hard for us for everything
we're doing right now to do both a
Wookie leaks and breakdowns for bad
batch we're doing neither currently
however however however we've heard
we've heard your prayers and we will be
doing breakdowns of the bad batch going
forward every episode I don't know but I
think Tommy's gonna do one that covers
everything okay okay the first few but
yeah I it's it was just hard we just
didn't know going into the new year I
was going to be out of the country so we
were really just kind of like trying to
just cover our bases we knew we wanted
to cover the last of us and now that
we're back we just kind of like we all
had a great meeting today and we're like
hey why don't we cover the bad batch too
check it out
yeah the bad bash will be massive
numbers for you but we aren't really
caring because here's what we wanted to
do going to the new year and new rock
stars didn't always do this in the past
but going into the forward is we want to
start covering more things that aren't
just marvel in Star Wars we're going to
continue covering Marvel and Star Wars I
mean bad batch is Star Wars but it's not
like live action star wars and we cover
Marvel way more than we do Star Wars as
it is but we want to start saying yes to
things we wouldn't always say yes to We
Saw Scream go up this week from Whitney
yeah Whitney he did a great job covering
that scream trailer
um uh Jessica I think is gonna be doing
a video about the menu yeah
um yeah Anna has been on our um Last of
Us after show she did a whole primer on
everything you didn't know going into
the last of us so yeah we're going to be
doing a lot more uh other types of
content if it's like a number one movie
that weekend we want to do a video about
it you know
I'm excited I can't wait for that deep
dive will they reach the end of the
first game of The Last of Us in season
one without spoiling things I mean I
don't know I haven't seen all the way to
the end of the show yeah but I I don't
know what happens I
what do we know about the show in
episode two
they're they're leaving the Boston
State Capitol building
oh oh because they okay yeah I could say
this
Ali is B is the whole point is Joel's
trying to deliver l in case you haven't
played the game I'm trying to make sure
I don't spoil anything Joel is supposed
to take Ellie to the the Firefly lab
base whatever
and um I feel like wherever that
destination is supposed to land I don't
think it's going to end there is what
I'm I think it'll end a little bit
before where the game the first game
actually ends okay yeah and I think
they're gonna
man I wish I could type it but I'm so
I'm aware that there's a lot of people
who haven't played the game but I I
don't a lot of people don't know the
presumption that they're gonna just
adapt the first game into a season and I
think they're going to do two-thirds of
the first game just based off the
episode count and [__] uh like that's
just where my mind's going and so I
won't say anything more but I feel like
they're only gonna do two thirds I think
they're gonna do all the first the whole
thing for the whole thing yeah just
because they think the fact that Craig
is working with Neil I think that's how
they've outlined it but I feel like they
have three seasons announced right now
they do but I think they're gonna split
the second game into
um the second games forever yeah it's a
very very long game yeah I think they
could get three seasons out of that
second game or they could go beyond it
or they could make different choices I
think many of you watching may wish that
they will make different choices when
they adapt the second game
we'll see I don't want to say too much
do it go all out do it sooner
before the first next episode
Howard's sus 13 so happy to thank you
for the Super Chat to see Eric doing
deep Dives these are my faves and always
cheer me and my bestie oh great thank
you so much and uh again please
subscribe to the Deep dive it's Deep
dive NR and I I know it's hard to see
how it will be different because it's
like what you already do deep Dives what
we're doing on New rockstars are just
breakdowns in comprehensive Easter egg
hunts right um which are very hard and
very rewarding to do and I'm gonna keep
doing them because I do like doing that
work but deep Dives it's gonna have a
different format it's going to have a
different feel a different vibe
different speed to it we're going to be
analyzing it from a different light it's
gonna be a bit indulgent it's gonna be a
bit more personal too I'm gonna open up
about my life and my personal connection
to all these things so something that I
normally leave on on the table for
because my anxiety has been no one cares
about that like no one wants to hear
that but now that it's my own channel
I'm like okay well maybe some people do
yeah I'd love to hear it let's hear
about your childhood traumas right here
on this live stream let's make this fun
four wounds you gotta subscribe
you're my core traumas go to the Deep
dive
uh do you think Kang will kill Scott nah
we need it Scott around he's gonna live
yeah I think when you do teases like
that in the trailer I'm like that's
right actually little a little tease of
our fifth piece of Deep dive content
that you'll see on launch day we're
gonna look at the art of trailer
deception I'm gonna do a full analysis
on what parts of how do you know when a
trailer is lying because we know
trailers are deceptive sure sure but how
specifically when in a trailer like what
shots can should we be suspect of and
why do trailers lie how have they
evolved over time is it okay when they
lie should they be sued when they lie
because now there is a lawsuit Universal
Studios being sued over the yesterday
movie trailer that that those lawsuits
are are nuts to me because I'm like
you're asking for so much money for
something that would have cost you like
ten to twenty dollars to buy it kind of
a ridiculous even last I think that two
people suing just rented it on these
yeah they paid 4.99 for it yeah
um like I think their time is that
valuable to the pointer they were just
so mad that Anna armis's subplot got cut
that's the only reason they watched
yesterday The Beatles movie it just
sounds like such a thing where you're
going is there a way we can sue for this
experience and like you don't you can't
genuine I could see being peeved by it
but I can't imagine someone being
genuinely upset to the point where they
feel they have to sue uh yeah I don't
know yeah they might be lawyers just
trying to get like you know it's just
some money I I don't know how it works
but hey a judge is allowing it to move
forward Universal try to get it thrown
out and the judge is like no there's a
case here you gotta prep it's
interesting it's an interesting
discussion to be had is it but it's like
there is some type of like Hulu movie to
make about the person who's who's on
[__] like that dude didn't know Eric
had legs
it's got very long legs
that that
feels weird I don't like looking at my
legs I'll cover them up oh that tune in
more for the Deep dive to understand why
Eric does not like looking at his own
legs
um let's see here resident nurman thank
you for the Super Chat all right guys we
should wrap this stream up soon I want
to take too much of your time man
I'm having a blast we've been here for
an hour what I feel like your time is
very valuable not that valuable it costs
300 every 30 minutes
300. wow I should start charging that
Resident nerdman says I love your
reviews and breakdowns who are you and
John and koi deconstruct films makes my
day love knowing film still has a place
in this world thank you of course the
film has a place in this world what an
interesting thing to say in the film
that there's too much film there's so
much film not enough not enough we need
more more releases every month
stop motion can take hours per second
and they say infinity war was yeah we
haven't really talked much about like
our our backstories I guess I went in
I'm I'm I much more enjoy I guess taking
uh questions from you guys and talking
to them but I you know there's a
fascinating man sitting next to me here
do you have a question I I want to know
how you got started doing this
I got started doing this because I
wanted to find uh I was I was actually
obsessed with Ebert and Roper yeah me
too the two thumbs up guys remember
though remember that day I remember
Cisco in Eber yeah then it was Eber and
Roper follow and then Roper took over
and then uh
[Laughter]
and it's funny seeing that because those
reviews were essentially two people
doing a Jeremy Johns review like just so
bite-sized like they were super short
reviews and I love that concept you know
and that's how we wanted to do it and
then um so when we started the channel
like it was John and I in the beginning
but we he was getting to college and and
and I so I just had to kind of take this
into my own hands and take it in my own
reins and then eventually like I was
said someone in the car to you it was
like I was working a full-time job at a
doctor's office and then I did 30 hours
a week uh pretty much doing YouTube uh
in the morning when I woke up on my
lunch break I would drive back do do
more YouTube and then I would do it
after after work and then all weekend
and then there was one month where I had
the biggest leap of faith where I was
like all right I think I can make this
channel work if I just quit my job and I
had no savings and I decided
let me just if I take all the hours I'm
doing at my job and just put it now to
YouTube I'm pretty sure I can make this
work and it was a big risk because I had
no money and then I managed to make I
remember I made
917 dollars which was just enough to
make my rent nice and I was like perfect
now if I could just make a little bit
more this would be awesome and I'm the
same guy who's had the same kind of
anxiety since it like I gotta I gotta
just constantly be doing this and so
yeah what about you what's your start am
I I weirdly I started by like getting
into critics for me it was uh Jeff
Jensen at Entertainment Weekly because I
would watch I know that yeah in college
yeah now he's like a screen artist right
I think he wrote for Legion I think he
was a writer on Legion on FX anyway but
yeah like growing up like seeing movies
with my mom like my dad was obsessed
with the movie Jaws so I would just
watch jaws with him and I didn't you
know it was wasn't until I re-watched a
scene where the sun is like mirroring
his dad's like depression just doing
this and then I was like oh that's why
because my dad loves his kids and that's
why he loves dogs so I was able to have
that connection my brother got me I
remember like we were watching a movie
and he's like all right I'm gonna go out
he's like what's next oh Pulp Fiction
you should watch that it's really cool
and I was like what he's like it's this
guy Quentin turns you know he the
movie's like it's out of order but
you'll like it I was like okay and I
just watched it and I was like oh my God
it blew my mind so I've had just a
family who just gave me great movie
recommendations and then uh watched got
it really in the lost and got really
into like writing about movies
um we're moved out to LA to be a
screenwriter wrote some movies didn't
sell any of them uh wrote for a Blog
called split cider where I was reviewing
Saturday Night Live and interviewing
like show Runners and that kind of
fascinating wow yeah those you can still
find those articles they're on um it's
now owned by vulture but I used to
really get into it I would create pie
charts of cast member screen time over
the season like Kate McKinnon's got a
big wedge
um and then the casts saw those articles
and started to freak out like why am I
not a human
why'd my sketch get caught uh and I did
that and then yeah I was working TV
production jobs for a while and then I
actually auditioned for what was then
New Media rock stars in 2015. I did a
screen test thought I did okay
um I didn't get the job but like the
people who did get the job were my
friends from The Improv community that I
had recommended for the job not
realizing I was recommending my
competition and they were just slightly
better looking they were the coys to me
it's okay they did a great job with it
they they're more telegenic than I was I
moved out to be a writer so I was like
I'm not gonna do this and I was brought
on to be a writer of these scripts So So
the plan wasn't even to be a host no I
mean I auditioned to be host I'm like
I'll take any so you kind of like a bit
of a Conan O'Brien journey I did yeah I
think that's yeah I mean yeah kinda I I
never intended to be on camera when I
moved out to LA
but then yeah I started to write a bunch
of these scripts and eventually I quit
my job I took a risk and like I think
that might have been a premature risk
because I had definitely had a year
where I was having trouble paying rent
just trying to write scripts in
rockstars because I was told that we it
would turn into full time like in a
couple months and it didn't so like at
least over a year so it was a bit of a
struggle a lot of anxiety for a year but
then eventually like things just kind of
shifted at first I thought I'm like I'm
totally gonna get fired this company's
gonna fall apart because we weren't
making any video like you can look at
from like February to like March or
April of 2016. there's like no videos
that came out of the new rockstars
Channel it wasn't until like Game of
Thrones came back and then like suddenly
the Channel's like we're gonna cover
this and then like still like scripts
weren't getting made things were coming
out way too late and uh and eventually
it all just fell in my lap
um which ended up being like a blessing
in disguise because then I was like okay
No One's Gonna
tell me not to make this video okay I
will make this video and then since then
I've just been kind of like deciding
figuring out what is the best kind of
content to do and a lot of it's just
been Guided by what do I want to analyze
the most what do I think has the most as
like the deepest layers to it and so in
the early months we were doing like
first season of stranger things but then
we would also do Legion you know that
show Legion Yeah you mentioned uh and
then um yeah it just kind of Grew From
There we've had a lot of luck we've had
a lot of great uh editors who have
helped us out like my buddy Devin and uh
it's just been able to we've had a lot
of just fortunate success and it's just
been because like I cannot stop writing
like I will write all night I was
telling you on the drive over here like
I'm getting five hours of sleep
currently and my body's like yeah that's
fine like that shouldn't be how it works
that's just turning brain yeah I
constantly have ideas of things to to
work on and I I will wake up in the
middle of the night and be like I want
to write another couple paragraphs of
this just because I won't be able to
sleep until I do and uh and luckily
we've just been able to add a lot of
great team members to to the new rock
stars family and I've just been able to
help us grow even more and the people
you see on screen are fantastic but also
there's a whole bunch of people behind
the scenes we have some amazing editors
um uh uh Josh heard is a guy who is like
the unsung hero of new rock stars over
the past few years he's so great and we
have uh an operations team uh our head
of operations Patty who's like saved new
rock stars at least eight different
times in the past 12 months how long
does it take to edit
let's say you have like a 20 minute
breakdown how long do you would you
would you would you take it that it
takes the editing team to edit one of
those if it's a 20 minute breakdown uh
for one that's just not there's a lot
yeah every well every host and writer in
new rockstars has a different uh pace
and a different approach to it what what
I do is like I try to limit myself to
only writing for four hours but if it's
like a 20 minute breakdown I probably
spent about 10 hours writing Jesus um
but it's because like say it's an
episode of um of moon night or something
yeah that night I've been working for
two and a half hours on it starting to
outline and write yeah uh and then I
wake up at like six or no no I wake up I
get six hours of sleep I'll wake up at
like eight and then I will uh and I'll
write all day and our deadline is at
like 5 PM I have to shoot by then oh
they they give you like deadlines yeah
because that's it's really just if if we
miss it then the video is going to come
out a day later yeah
um and then we have an amazing group of
freelance editors who we've been able to
to work with over the past few years so
if it's like a 20 minute video there's
usually two or three editors that are
all working on different chunks of it at
the same time wow overnight or the next
morning once they're done they send it
back to one of our full-time editors who
stitches it all together cleans it up
and then hopefully we're able to review
it so yeah for them for like a seven or
eight minute chunk they get I mean I
think the rate is like you get an hour
per minute is the rate they move at wow
because you've seen our videos have a
lot of assets and a lot of Animation I
think some can work faster than that but
that's the rate we look at it that's an
hour per minute I might be wrong our
editor's gonna be like you bonehead you
don't know if you guys are understanding
this if it's being said is that it would
take one hour to edit one minute of a
video I think one one in an hour right
one manner so if you see a 40 minute
video there was 40 man hours of
post-production that went into that yeah
and there's a lot of videos
that's kind of how Devin works right now
for the Deep dive he's able to get you
know working eight hour days able to get
about an eight minute chunk finish Jesus
so these videos are one division two
dive is 55 minutes long yeah yeah so
that means it was 55 of Devin's hours
winning oh my God yeah wow and I spent
probably a few days writing that script
too like I spent a long time re-watching
everything re-watching it again getting
like a new because I didn't want to just
like rehash through I mean there are
some things that are a bit redundant
because I'm like no but I've mentioned
this before but there's another layer to
it that trust me but I was able to find
like so many more things and there was a
lot of research from our One Division
stuff that I just left out of it because
I'm like I don't know if this is
significant but like you know I look
back at our Mephisto speculation I
realized that there was something to it
you know bring it back the pistol
obviously wasn't in this show but like
but like there is like Wanda's grief is
sentient in that show there is a third
entity that is controlling both Wanda
and Agatha in that who who is that who
is that that's a force someone is
puppeting [__] and I don't think it was
Mephisto yet but we'll see how my Fisto
is involved I think one I think Agatha
knew who Mephisto was I think Agatha has
a history with Mephisto that just didn't
come up I love the idea you just accept
defeat no then you go back through it
and you're like oh my God
[Laughter]
there's more evidence you're like that
detective who won't let the case go no
yeah absolutely not the Killer's still
out there Derek the guy you have in
prison is not the right guy
just can't let it go
I love it I love it I love it
um
let's see here
this is fun Paul little
Loeb and R and R what does that mean
new rockstars and real rejects what does
lobe mean I don't know it could be love
any roads yes that is much more accurate
um I was about to really try to
deconstruct the word though
um curious how NR uh deep down with
different Philips new film wise Channel
since he's behind that and you rock
stars any insight you'll have to ask
Philip about that uh so Philip has moved
on from new rockstars he's filmwise is
his own independent thing so I'm really
excited for him I'm like because you
know Philip was part of new rock stars
in the early years and uh and like I
really liked it when he used to do
videos because I think he's got a great
brain for this stuff
um and so I'm really excited to see what
he does with this new channel of his I
wish him all the best as it goes on this
new thing because let's see uh it was
part of the process with you uh being
part of new rockstars in the beginning
right yeah yeah he was he was what got
me onto the channel I knew him in
college uh and like the reason the only
reason why I started to be on camera at
new Roxas because Philip got an new job
like every year since like 2016 Philippa
said like the guy has so many different
irons in the fire like I I'm so
fascinated by how his brain works
because like he got hired I think I defy
media and then he was on Source fed for
a while and then he's had a lot of other
like side Ventures that he's tried out
year after year after year
um so as he's been working on all that
other stuff that's why like making
videos for new rock stars fell into my
lap got it got it yeah so
um well I can't wait to see watch them
go Toe to Toe see what happens to you
guys yeah I really don't know what's
going on with that like yeah I'm curious
to see what what he does with it watch I
mean yeah that'd be exciting let's see
it happen then you can react to his
videos and then you re and then we all
just react to each other yeah
that's just massaging each other let's
see how how far behind are we okay let's
go let's do a speed round and catch up
on supers and then we'll do a couple
last questions and we got to call it
um let's put this away for a sec Let me
refresh this please don't make me sign
back in to my own account YouTube
do you guys get age restrictions on your
videos ever uh sometimes sometimes but
we try to keep it uh you know we'll edit
around things we'll blur stuff but yeah
sometimes just from the weirdest stuff
we'll get age restrictions like and we
don't really know what it was about it
it's a pain in the ass it is the worst
this video is probably age restricted
honestly just for a couple of swear
words okay yeah we're a little bit
behind here all right oh yeah we're very
behind here oh my God all right we're
gonna we're gonna do this a fit a
Quality quality efficient answers coming
in
very soon
Fair months are there I got a lot of
super chats yeah thank you guys it's
really really simple I love it thank you
so much thank you
thank you
trying to get to the part where we last
left
um
almost there
lobe new Rockstar okay I remember yeah
all right it's b3n here we go uh thank
you it's B3 hey Eric and Greg how do you
think Sean Chi versus Kang will go down
he's gonna punch him I hope Kang steals
some rings and we get a brief fight like
Shang Chi and his dad yeah ooh I think
there is a link between Kang and the uh
in the 10 there has to be right there's
just I don't know if it'll be like overt
in quantumania some people say the
visuals of the those big Rings might be
connected to the 10 rings but yeah I
don't know I think there's a connection
with the Bengal in Kang like Iman
villani seemed to indicate that there
was going to be the inscription what's
gonna be like a Kang thing I remember
she gave me some exclusives on that yeah
she's blue she's right there being like
I'll give it I'll give Eric the juicy
details but uh I am excited for I'm
excited for Daniel what's his [__]
name the director correct Creighton
Creston Destin Daniel [__] God damn it
yeah yeah I'm excited for that it's
crazy that he got the opportunity to be
doing this Avengers movie yeah they did
an excellent job how that Ensemble yeah
and then introduce a new world I did an
excellent job
thank you
thoughts on born again any predictions
uh born again I'm super excited I I am
great I'm local I'm cautiously I'm a
little nervous a little nervous because
like this is Disney plus you think it's
going to tone down the violence uh yeah
I don't know there's a big argument
about like it doesn't matter I'm like
well if you're pulling into Netflix
where it's like doing Expendables 3
after Expendables too and and it's not
just because it was cool because it was
violent uh Daredevil Netflix like it it
it sort of represented something it felt
more real and because it because the
violence truly had the violence in
itself was a character in a lot of ways
in in the Netflix show so that's why
like it's it always said something more
about the characters and the violence
was there it wasn't just gratuitous to
be gratuitous no it was the
characterization it was in thematic
weight to it that's why the head
smashing scene is so memorable for so
many people because it's gory as it is
it like really showed you this soft
smoking guys a real monster you know
like it really said a lot or even in the
next in the episode before or after I
forget which one where the guy like
throws his head by three he's like just
to avoid the right yeah of Kingpin kills
himself on it's like yeah I mean you
could have jumped off a ledge you could
have crushed up some sleeping pills but
I think it says a lot like and having
that violence show it is just makes it
that much more it creates attention and
adds to the mood and so that's why I
but I know it's not everything I have no
idea what they're gonna do with this
show that like it's so many episodes I'm
like what the hell is it gonna do I mean
it could be a really great legal drama I
like the legal side of it the Punisher
uh him him yeah the trial of the
Punisher was awesome season two yeah I
feel like season two gets a lot of crap
but I I like season two I like that Arc
it's the Elektra Arc of season two that
wasn't crazy about it yeah but I still
I still liked a lot of it just some of
it was a little slow yeah that's true I
mean when it gets like the hand in
ninjas and [__] like they have no
heartbeats or whatever
um yeah it starts to lose you a little
bit yeah a little bit PJ pandemic Jones
one of our top patrons as well
um he says uh what's up boys wish I
could stay but I'm going to theater to
see Infinity but we'll have fun oh I've
heard not I've heard in uh okay big fan
Eric look forward to the upcoming
Ant-Man stuff in the Deep dive much
loved boys I've heard in the way how the
menu was more of uh sometimes not so
subtle but a more subtle commentary on
you know classism and the rich and all
that that the infinity pool is the much
more uh overt destructive gory violent
version have you seen the trailer for it
it's David cronenberg's son I think yeah
I saw the trailer for it it looks gnarly
yeah it looks crazy and Tommy and
Jessica were able to see a sneak preview
of it and said it was pretty wild yeah
it seems like a really uncomfortable
experience uh Moment of Silence from
thick Tracy thank you
Annie banani moment of silence thick
Tracy we got an insult Super Chat these
are the best okay I love it now this
could either be for me or you
of it could be either let's assume that
they need it for both those mean it for
both ask why he fakes his reactions and
I'll ask you first Eric why do you fake
your reactions for the views baby for
those yummy yummy views
I don't fake my reactions but the the
emotions I heighten them sometimes
heighten them but it's like the re the
joy I'm feeling is real the emotion is
real but like every time you see me on
camera you think that's the authentic
mean you think I'm walking around saying
hi welcome back to talking to me right
now here's how I feel about a movie no
I'm on camera that's like part of my job
I think what I always tell like anyone
who comes by here on the channel
is I I like to let this be the outlet to
express how you're feeling internally
that's what I always tell everyone is
whatever you're feeling internally just
let it like let it's kind of an acting
exercise and you say acting that sounds
like pretending but like no a big part
of acting is being willing to express
your emotions and so that's what I
always encourage people to do when
they're here with me is like all you're
doing is whatever so if you feel like
crying let it out that's what if
someone's crying you're not gonna be
like fake like you're crying but a lot
of times people will actually shy away
from letting themselves cry and I'll
I'll be like no if you feel like crying
cry makes a good thumbnails too but I'm
like also they're gonna clip that out as
an example of how that's why you cry
thumbnails dude
um but also uh no if you're feeling like
I I know what it's like to kind of feel
a little like be in a crowd of people
who are excited and feel that but be
timid to share it and and be in unison
with others and now I I've always let
this be the outlet to show that yeah and
that's what I let other people do I
think Tracy if you think I'm faking my
reactions at least you can take some
pleasure in the fact that when I have
fallen out of my chair I really did hurt
myself that time so I got a bruise for
it so you know I physically got hurt I'm
not going to a theater screaming let's
go I'm not that guy talk to them about
maybe why they fake their reactions
because I'm not going to annoy you in a
movie theater with my reaction maybe I
should start doing that yeah everyone I
wrote a lot of those
[Music]
over here
um we know what you're referencing here
um
Eric have you gone to any uh San
Francisco uh San Francisco yeah that is
it right sketchfest is happening right
now I think right now I have not gone
but tomorrow Friday I will be at the
stageworks theater it's not part of
sketchfest but it is I'm part of a
improv theater company called end games
oh nice very fun and end games end games
they had their name before before them
Avengers end game yeah that one little
movie yeah but uh it's a really really
funny group of people we're doing a show
on um on Friday it's gonna be our last
show in that location before we move to
another location it's gonna blast
awesome where's it located it's on
Valencia Street 446 Valencia Street in
the mission all right and if you're out
and about near there go for it I'm just
gonna get whatever please because I
yelled and I did that bit because you
were faking your bit
Olivia Hamlin thank you for being here
again buddy uh you've been here quite a
few times
hey Eric
following this stream following the
stream should we expect an NR breakdown
about Greg's house and how you can prove
John is being held captive against his
will hashtag must debunk uh no because I
don't want the police to find this place
and um and I I think John has some
Stockholm syndrome and I don't want to
take that away from him that's the only
reason John is still on this channel
yeah because we keep him keep him locked
up
the real rock stars are the new rejects
you decide those are honestly good names
they're both good they're both good new
rejects I honestly I think those are
both better than the names we have
that's actually real Rockstar is better
in new Texas yeah I would take either of
those over what I have they actually
work it actually work super well new
rejects uh thank you Alan Gibbs Mustafa
jav if oh it is a good one if Wes
Anderson had a direct a Marvel movie
what character should be in it I vote
for Guardians of the Galaxy
all those you don't like those offices
Guardians of the Galaxy but I would want
something more grounded right
yeah I think a Wes Anderson Vision The
Defenders A Vision Quest by Wes Anderson
would be fun just like processing the
world through his eyes I mean some of
those wanted Vision episodes could have
been directed by Wes Anderson right oh a
thousand percent yeah I would love a
good Wes Anderson
um
Batman movie
real quirky sad or an animal randomly
dies
I do I do like a good Wes Anderson I
haven't seen enough Wes Anderson some
people call me a loner but I'm just
misunderstood
John Stevens music comes in yeah played
by Adrian Brody that'd be great
um Samuel Thomas you guys think Deadpool
will show up in secret Wars a thousand
percent I think of course well I mean
we'll see him before Secret Wars and
Deadpool three yeah at that point you're
gonna see everybody in secret Wars you
think like Hugh Jackman's Wolverine will
be a huge difference I think Robert
Downey Jr is coming back I think Toby
they're gonna find a way to get Toby in
there yeah it's gonna be crazy it's
probably gonna be two moves Nicholas
Cage Ghost Rider yeah yeah you think so
Ben Affleck irritable yeah uh David
Hassel Hoffman Fury yeah yeah they're
all gonna be there there's ways to do it
Ben Affleck's Daredevil
Rupert Jamison either of you playing
Hogwarts Legacy no I'm not I haven't
played it yet I and as you know I don't
really have time for video games right
now oh my God you got the best way out
just saying that because there's a lot
of the conversation happening yeah I'm
unaware I went on Twitter one day I was
like any controversy it could be
controversial playing this game it does
look interesting I gotta admit it does
look like an interesting game I'm not
pining to play it I'm still making my
way through God of War Ragnarok but it
could be cool
um Venom Carnage I'd say Tom Holland
should play Superman
it's not a plane it's not a bird
it's me Superman
hey Lois wow so the sun's energy gives
me power
so bewildered or or he's morning
I'm Nathan Drake
you could just I heard he's gonna be
planes like that rumor of him being
Zorro I was like please God for the love
of God please don't he doesn't want to
do that I think Tom Hall is actually a
great actor though have you have you
seen some of his other that was great
yeah the the devil all the time yeah it
was great in that cherry Cherry's good
even his debut movie The Impossible oh
yeah yeah but he's a little kid yeah he
didn't know what his range was yet yeah
he was good though so kid play scared
a tsunami
oh geez there is a bit of a Morty
there's a Morty thing about it what he's
doing he's doing Michael J fox yeah the
Pratt Falls the comedic energy yes
there's a video that need to be made on
how Tom Holland's Peter Parker is
Michael Jackson yeah Marty McFly
thousand percent I think he said that
directly that he that he wants I mean
pull from the best right yeah
hey Tony
with the trailers that have come out for
Ant-Man and what we know of the
characters so far how do you think the
movie will go down or what would you do
what would I do well if I were shrunken
in the corner yeah
uh or what would you do with them
have you read honestly have you read the
script leaked I haven't read the script
no I haven't read it in fact I didn't
even hear about it in a couple until a
couple days later by then it was just
apparently
taken off the web yeah
[Laughter]
not that I could prep a breakdown a
little bit early yeah yeah uh no I have
not seen it I've uh I mean a lot of
people have like tweeted at me out of
context lines of dialogue that might be
from this but I don't I they don't make
any sense to me like I don't know who
says it or what it's in reference to I
don't remember what you said in the
break room uh did you say that you think
Hank pin might die
I feel like he might die Brandon said
Hank Pym might die I think it'd be weird
to kill him I think it's more likely
that uh uh I I think Modoc it would be
weird for that version to have a future
which I've always felt that from the
from the first time it was like reported
that uh Corey stole is gonna be playing
mode I just think that's weird yeah
because there's another version of Modoc
out there like they should do Modoc
Modoc so like a mandarin thing where
it's like it's too big of a character to
change that way so I think it's just
kind of a one-off type of deal yeah yeah
and then after Secret Wars we'll get a
real Modoc yeah that'd be nice
I think you can pull off Modoc in live
action you know who could pull it off
James gunning could have pulled off a
real Moto he could have done it but they
don't [__] up you lost them it's just
a crazy story with James Gunn I know
just to go from like being fired yeah
and back again the same gun tail it's in
sun it's it's in sun it's insane
it's in Sun what's going on with James
Gunn Jonathan Sullivan hi Craig and Eric
hi are there any movies you're sort of
embarrassed to admit you haven't seen
keep up the good work I have not seen
most of the Friday the 13th movies I
have not seen most of the
uh
uh actually the horror slasher
characters I haven't seen most of the
movies okay yeah I haven't seen a lot of
those movies I can't really because
there's so many sequels like I've seen
the first of all of them yeah and I I've
seen a lot of The Nightmare on Elm
Streets because I got into that as a kid
so I saw the yeah at least through Dream
Warriors which I think is the third one
I have a whole bunch of movies and then
I watched the fourth one too Freddy's
New Nightmare saw that one I haven't
seen Field of Dreams oh
you have a cry I haven't seen the
original Willy Wonka
how have you missed that one because the
giant up one was too good and I said I'm
not gonna ruin it with some Gene Wilder
[__] I'm trying to think um it's
creepy as hell uh but it's great it's a
classic I haven't seen Leon the
Professional that
yeah that's at the top of my list of
movies
on the professional well there's the
professional and then there was Leon the
Professional okay
um like it's it's one's the like the
director's cut but that one is you know
that's the one where Gary Oldman goes
everyone I know the meme of it but I
don't know the context of that scene oh
my God it's a fantastic it's Luke based
on his best movie okay yeah it's it's
like I know Lucas on often does like
cheesy action films now but it is a
genuinely great movie I will check it
out oh my God yeah you would love that I
mean yeah it's on my list it's hard
there's a lot of stuff I gotta get there
and it's so cool
[Laughter]
um
I mean I've been the benefit of me not
having seen movies is I can do a
reaction here on the channel like
Schindler's List for the first time a
month ago
um that's a fun movie you should break
that down that would be a very funny
yeah I I rewatched it with Kelly uh like
a couple years ago and I was like look I
know it's considered one of the saddest
most horrifying movies of all time but
you know what they're there's some
light-hearted moments in it and she's
like what and I was like trust me it's
Steven Spielberg he puts lighthearted
moments in all of his movies and I
rewatched it and I said Kelly I'm so
sorry and it was like right when the
scene where the kids are in the truck
and they wait oh no and I was like I'm
so sorry there's one gag in the movie
and it's not even that funny it's kind
of mean now it's where Oscar Schindler's
taking
um interviews for a secretary and he's
like it's all these beautiful women he's
like oh yes oh yes oh yes as they're
typing slowly he gets like first and
then they're back here there's one who's
just a little more humble he's like he's
just like bored that's the one joke in
the movie and I remember that thinking
the movie was filled with that no that's
one scene in An otherwise haunting
beautifully made movie yeah everyone
needs to see but it's not a charmer yeah
as you know I mean yeah I know that was
a that was a hard one to sit through to
me it felt it still holds up it's a
weird Timeless film because it's from
the 90s but it feels like it could have
been it genuinely feels like it could
have been made just like a year ago or
yeah oh yeah
um Bryce uh no wait Eric Miller thank
you for the moment of silence
Bryce Burris thank you re-watching lost
for the first time in 10 plus years I've
never heard more lost conversation in
the last few years than I have today
that just keeps coming up to I mean if
you if you get in a conversation with me
lost is going to come up a few times do
you on that show I'll just ask you this
do you like the ending yeah I do and I
haven't seen the ending but I've kind of
heard it I do I think it's great this is
great I don't know it was great but it's
good I think it it's fine but it works
for you it's fine it's over hated I
think fair enough that's a good way to
put it I think that shows did a lot of
great stuff
a lot of exciting things I would like to
revisit it I would like to do a video
here where I watch just the first one
the first episode and the last episode
you could but you'd miss out the the
journey in between I mean the the first
episode is one of the best Pilots ever
made yeah of a TV show you could just
start with the pilots see how you feel
and then go you know [__] that I'm gonna
actually watch the whole thing right it
feels like a movie it's weird to think
2004. if you watch TV in 2004 the budget
was really limited on ABC shows CBS NBC
shows they didn't have these kind of
budgets but this one JJ Abrams directed
it and went crazy it was a Monumental
show yeah it was my it was I could not
stop hearing about it yeah the mystery
craft was great unfortunately JJ Abrams
had no plan Beyond just the mystery
building that was the day of TiVo yeah
so that's right that's I only watched it
I watched it on TiVo it's fast forward
yeah and I didn't have TiVo so that's
why I couldn't watch it but I give all
the credit in the world to Damon
Lindelof and Milton Kusa to take over
that show and make it make sense and I
think they did a pretty good job that
was a good I imagine it was a good show
I've seen some of them
Benjamin uh uh not nash sanadiki uh if
Greg is playing Abby do you own a nine
iron Club well
um
for my interpretation to Abby you're
just gonna need
Paris Hilton and Nicole Richie right
here that's the names I came up with I
love it
simple life with Greg film wise and deep
down prayers why do we have to fight
um can't we all just get get along
Benjamin B thank you for the Super Chat
who would you each pick to direct and
star in a live-action Century movie
oh
[Laughter]
that's the point when you're an hour and
a half or two of livestream there I
don't I don't [__] Will Smith's star
and direct at Live Action Center movie
he can direct it and star in it who's
the main pick for Sentry that people
have is it Henry Cavill is kind of like
the top casting choice they just want
something for him Matthew Vaughn and and
uh directing and Henry Cavill would be
the pick okay that sounds great I've
done longer streams Eric you can hang it
in there buddy
just hang in there man that's the
hardest question for people ask like all
right right now play casting director
cast like the Fantastic forecast all the
X and I'm like dude I don't know I don't
know who the young actors are I want
them to cast people I've never heard of
before right right go to some Community
Theater in Alberta Canada and cast
someone to play Wolverine and I don't
want to have ever heard of them before
it just casts into play it and I'll fall
in love with them if they're a good
actor so you don't have any fan picks
for anything no I I don't like I mean I
mentioned I put the video idea to you
and you didn't seem to
interface
Hal Jordan I think is kind of fun but
like sure when I'm watching movies it's
kind of like they already become too
famous I don't want them to play the
superhero I just want them to do like
small weird Art House movies and I I
love what Robert Pattinson did with his
career right he did the Twilight movies
made a [__] ton of money and then he's
like I'm gonna make a bunch of weird
movies for six years and it panned out
he made that 911 movie yeah remember me
right yeah we didn't know it was a 911
movie it's a 911 movie yeah and then he
made uh the lighthouse which was years
after that was kind of at the end of it
and then that's what happened in between
then he got Batman and I think he did
remember me in between some of the
Twilight movies too I don't know what
that was a weird career can I awkwardly
scoot you in no just slightly out of
frame all right we got this we got this
there [__] you're free we're almost you
know what let me just make sure I can
just do a proper refresh over properly
caught up and then oh my God we got this
there's never too many super chats we
just gotta start answering their
questions stop [__] around yeah yeah
no I mean
we we didn't need to plug your deep dive
thing
right there it was so stupid idiot
you signed you signed up for this bad I
did this is this is where we're at okay
now we're back okay we got too many to
wrap up we've got this let's see what do
we got any anime breakdowns coming to
new rock stars uh not right now and you
can blame Japan because Japanese blame
Japan biggest Japanese companies don't
have the same fairies use right so they
will sue us if we ever cover anime so a
lot of great anime creators out there
are having a lot of trouble getting
their content reactions which are
totally should fall under fair use Japan
doesn't honor that that's why there's a
lot of Godzilla content we don't do
either because they're very litigious so
it's hard to do anime content and make
this a business it'd have to be a hobby
at that point that's why we do our anime
reactions for patreon because I've I
know too many reaction channels really
like their channels get shut down for a
couple weeks because of that and we just
can't afford that we got a high
production we gotta we gotta keep
churning videos out over here
uh but thank you for the question Chris
Leto yeah Zach albach uh thank you for
the Super Chat who do you want to be
Booster Gold and they need new TCU
answer a fantastic question yeah no I
thought well this is one I thought about
the guy who plays a homelander in uh in
the boys
Anthony Starr yeah oh nice if he could
ever get out of Spanish prison
because didn't he get in a fight with a
chef in Spain he's out and he went to
prison you think he's out okay so I'm
doing something all right thank you
broke him out
some weird celeb controversy Michael Bay
killing pigeons there's so much
happening right now but that's a good
pick for Booster Gold I think it'd be
great that's a really good pick great
the movie guy thank you for the Super
Chat would you be interested in having a
reaction to Foundation For All Mankind
or any Apple TV shows yeah we want to do
Severance
Severance is awesome I haven't seen Love
Story yeah it's one of my favorite
things that came out in 2022. Severance
the bear
everything everywhere at once those are
your top three yeah things that came out
yeah how do you feel about top gun
Maverick getting best adapted screen
before yeah it deserves it I love Top
Gun I feel like that movie was awesome I
felt like maybe screenplay though they
were like other movies that definitely
deserved if the screenplay category gets
gets can like I mean you're a
screenwriter so you understand this but
for everyone else is like you think
screenplay is really great dialogue oh
they had a really great Christmas
I've seen people who don't understand
you know how hard it is to structure a
good movie it's the structure good
action that takes a lot of good writing
mainly the Top Gun structure
I don't know about that it's mainly the
structure there are some parallels to it
but I think the you're right they are
training for a mission and they go on
the mission do you think the Batman's a
better screenplay than top gun Maverick
um no I think top gun Maverick is a
better screenplay I think it's a better
because I'm I care more about structure
look I love top gun Maverick top five
favorite films of last year for sure so
I think that Batman had I like that
opening monologue but there's the rest
of it like structurally that movie has
Beats to it that don't need to be in the
movie okay fair enough like Batman
relearns things that we already know
sure that mystery plot like the audience
shouldn't be ahead of the detective
generally in mystery plots and there are
times where the audience like we know
Batman
just go over that don't go back to your
apartment it was three hours you don't
need to go back to the back pay back
cave to analyze this you could have
analyzed it there in the crime scene we
all know we'll know what happened fair
enough I love that movie I don't seem
like I'm hating on the Batman I love
that movie
it's in my top ten of it all right I
have people yelling at me for months now
like why are you on the backpack it's a
good movie it's a good movie Resident
Nerd Man
Joe Rogan Experience when oh man that'd
be good I wouldn't say I wouldn't say no
that would be enough that would be cool
he'll never ask me I'm not cool enough
to be able to oh you don't know that he
would totally ask you
um yeah no you've been on Good Morning
America
they haven't asked me back and now
you're here
started from the bottom now we're here
sorry man
Alex is that Nerf rack God we can't we
can't get uh we gotta get this going
yeah Alex C Easter egg must be preserved
to honor its Rocky Horror Roots okay do
you understand what that means no I've
seen Rocky Horror Picture Show probably
three times a night maybe they just mean
like there there are like Easter eggs in
that movie there's referring to a
specific thing I haven't seen Rocky
Horror Picture I watched it like uh
several times in college I used to watch
it like every year our Student Union
would have a screen of it and we do like
the special midnight screens where you
know you throw spoons and stuff like
that oh how fun and he's like oh they
did that out in La too yeah yeah yeah I
never went to the one in La though I
would just react to it by myself here
that's the Ultimate Experience yeah
raccoon shampoo are you a doctor who fan
Eric I haven't I haven't watched enough
doctor I've seen like one-off episodes
of it but I'm I'm gonna get there I'm
sorry I know I think you would actually
like it I think I would really love it
too yeah I think you would really dig it
yeah I like Doctor Who I just made it to
Jody Whitaker everyone's favorite season
uh Alex salveta
thank you Alex hi guys love the chat you
think you're making like really good
speed on it
love the channels and content
it's good Jesus Christ Eric we need more
of you on your channel you're the OG you
hear that people people want more Eric
a lot more Eric on the Deep dive what do
you guys think uh Ironman rdj's future
is in Marvel and will we see him much
love him oh you're lint I think we're
gonna get a lot more of uh not a lot
more but we'll get on I think he'll come
back in secret Wars yeah yeah at least
for Cameo he's not doing too much
RDJ he's not doing too much have you
seen his Dave Letterman interview no I
should check it out so insightful he's
got his production company now that is
making Perry Mason which is one of the
best things on HBO a new Season's coming
out this year and he's got a lot of
money he's got a little dizzy there God
yeah right yeah I'm good you're getting
used to this man it's well it's because
I only sleep five hours a night and I
stare at screens all day I'm just trying
to make it hard to get the dizzies I
tried adding this a while ago we just
kept going on tangents
um Josh
welcome back to real rock stars I'm Eric
Alba welcome back to your real Rockstar
again real Rockstar that's how you start
your videos your name new rejects you do
this like
oh yeah I kind of do do the side
[Music]
how do you both decide what movies TV
shows to cover and who covers them that
must be for you
um I uh I mean look we kind of know
what's in our wheelhouse but if it's
like it's a movie that you guys are
really excited about it's kind of you
guys usually tell us what you want us to
cover and we kind of listen to you or we
try to if we're doing our jobs right
we're listening to you
um yeah we're like and it's not just uh
we have like our list of things that we
try not to cover we try not to cover
like
uh politics or drama or kind of big news
headlines Johnny Depp trial we try not
to cover that stuff that would have been
a great breakdown I think we could have
done a good breakdown one thing one
pitch that I really wanted to do I
wanted to break down zaprooter's style
did did Harry Styles spit on Christmas
at that film festival I wanted to do a
breakdown of that people were like no
it's not on brand I'm like oh but I
could have done a great book oh man
that's what I did I did want to break
down the slab the the I did Pitch that
but that was such like a Charged yeah
controversial thing and the rest of the
new rockstars team is like we don't want
to get people yelling at us like I think
we can do in a respectful way I don't
know if we could have a respectful way
maybe it was smart that we didn't do
that uh but that that was that was a
great dude did you watch the Oscars live
I watched it live that was [__]
phenomenal happened yeah that's the
greatest moment oh my God that was not a
joke like when Chris Rock said this is
the greatest moment in television
history I'm like that guy was not
kidding around
John Martin I uh thank you John Martin
uh I would love to see a Ben Affleck
Batman versus Predator set in 90s La
what
obviously
why that that sounds great if we can get
Predator to fight Batman am I Ben
Affleck Batman in the 90s I know there's
a predator
but who is this is it that way he's more
of an underdog right less experienced I
don't think Ben Affleck left the city of
Boston until like 1997. yeah and his Bat
his Bruce Wayne was from Boston in the
in the 90s he was I'm thinking days and
Confused Ben Affleck he was in Austin
Texas he was in Dazed and Confused yeah
dude you gotta watch Days of confused I
haven't seen days he plays one of the
best character like well everyone in
that movie's the best character but he
plays the one of the most fun characters
why he just plays a huge prick yeah you
have to see Leon the professionals yeah
I think I did he really wanted I've seen
every movie but I think you say I'm a
failure you haven't seen the professors
yeah we don't know what we're talking
about uh anchovy live uh thank you for
the Super Chat thoughts on watching the
show Barry it's amazing it is amazing I
love Barry Oh I'm glad we love it
fantastic Bill Hader I cannot wait for
him to make a true film he'd be great in
re as Reed Richards
ooh it's been a pitch of mine for a long
time wow that's a great pick he's being
I've never thought of that that would be
a perfect there's other roles he could
play but I think
I think he's a very underrated director
the way he directs the [__] out of that
[__] yeah he's pretty good
um it's always so tempting to go on a
tangent risk Runner 101 I love you both
so much we love you we don't even know
you but we love you you guys are
incredible and amazing so are you there
are a lot of films coming out this year
what is your most anticipated and why do
you have a most anticipated I'm weirdly
curious about Indiana Jones for some
reason that always pops up my mind yeah
I think that'll be fun like I'm really
excited for Barbie
I weirdly have like those films really
weird I like what Greta Gerwig makes
um I didn't I wasn't big on white noise
uh which she kind of co-produced with
with no Obama I'm turning off the super
chats guys so you you can't in send more
in but we appreciate everyone who did we
want to just make sure we make the last
rounds of them I don't know but yeah
obviously I'm super excited for like
quantumania I'm excited for Guardians
volume three I think of all the Marvel
titles that's the one other than Loki
season two I think Loki season two is
gonna rock but I I forget it uh is
Guardian I know Winter Soldier is like
you're is that your favorite one
Guardian in the past when I've ranked it
Guardians was my favorite followed by
Winter Soldier I kind of go back and
forth on them but I still think I Gotta
Give the love to the first Guardians
movie I just love the uh that's my
favorite one yeah it's fun I like that
it's like a diegetic musical I just
think it's so wild yeah I love that one
a lot that is uh
I'm not a big fan you like part two
though right I do I don't like it as
much as part one but I like it I'm not a
big fan of part two
um
we're good uh what are your thoughts on
COBRA Kai season do you watch Cobra kai
no I need to watch Cobra Kai too son of
a [__] yeah I gotta check that out I
watched the very first episode of Cobra
Kai and I meant to stick with it and I
just got sidetracked it's fun because
they're always shooting in LA and I love
seeing like all these locations yeah I'm
like oh I got a burger there yeah so are
you like I used to live right there I
took a [__] there
if you live in L.A you just take shits
anywhere I pulled over after four hours
of traffic to take a [__]
um
uh Rockstar's rejects team up this has
been a good team up this has been a
great team it is like miyagiro and Cobra
Kai fighting uh I think uh I I said in
the season five at the end I was like I
feel like they have one more season left
in them and so yeah I think it's a
perfect time to wrap it up you want to
go out on a high note I know that can be
some some shows like to be I remember
one time The Walking Dead people were
like we could go for like 20 Seasons I'm
like yeah
uh I think it's always best to end on a
high note and I feel like they got at
least one more great season left in them
so it would be I think after that you're
just stretching it out yeah I think so
too and then he'll come back
um Bill Carnes thank you Bill Carnes uh
with the new Evil Dead Rise trailer
which got to you worse the cheese grater
eating glass glass that sounds awful I
didn't see the trailer you haven't seen
the trailer I haven't seen the trailer
yet
can you stop
you could have taken two minutes no to
watch the most morbid trailer
baby get over here stop eating that food
get over here yeah
um it's a disturbing trade okay well
I'll check it out the eating the glass
that was the part that really got to me
the cheese grater didn't even really
bother me
because I'm a sick human being Bruce
Bryce Burruss have either of you guys
watched the last Kingdom I have not but
I see it trending all the time have you
seen it no
I don't know what it is but we
appreciate the Super Chat thank you
Bryce Natalie thank you Natalie Mephisto
that's right does that really follow you
around yep does it bother you no
because you've kind of like coined
there is a way where you are somewhat
like within the comic realm because of
it now that's amazing I love him I mean
I was I thought that my um what I was
known for was kind of already locked in
like a few years ago like 2018 2019 I'm
like I'm just gonna be someone who's
known as like a kind of a movie analyst
comic book YouTuber and then one
division happened and then I transformed
into this guy
and uh I'm fine with it I think it's
totally fine I I've embraced it and I
think it's a good thing that we all look
around every dark corner for um
I cannot wait to see your video when
Mephisto actually does come up
supposedly in a show later on this year
he already has it yeah he already has
he's already been there he's there he's
been everywhere
um
yeah one division kind of changed the
game for everyone I I feel like
it's it's not in camera you can't see it
but there's a big one division poster
it's my favorite one of my favorite
posts pointing to Batman yeah yeah
there's a giant ass One Division poster
back here displayed
um haunted Autumn lately my life has
been scored by the running out of Air
theme this collaboration has been the
air bubble I needed thank you hashtag
Sonic oh no that's what they're
referencing that was a long time ago I'm
glad I'm glad we uh
yeah it's it's in my head that music is
playing in my head
do you have a theme song
[Laughter]
Mr thank you haunted Autumn it's really
kind Mr Flixster hey guys big fan y'all
inspire me to start my own channel
really me not just Eric but either one
of you like to collaborate with me gotta
hit up Eric 300 every 30 minutes it's
worth it I think it's too much busy ask
him on Cameo I should go on camera you
should get a cameo oh my God make all
that extra bucks you and Chris Tucker
um
random it's that part of the streamer
Miranda do you think we're gonna get the
MCU Fantastic Four casting announcement
this year we better yeah man I'm so mad
they didn't announce that a d23 there's
like and uh Matt shackman's here stand
up Matt you're gonna be fired from this
no didn't he get fired no he's still on
it who did get fired uh not Betty
Alvarez uh the [__] guy did
Spider-Man no way home yeah so Matt
shockman just stood up in the crowd and
waved at everyone it was already
reported it was already writing thanks
yeah I'm here yeah
but yeah they got it they have Comic-Con
again this year and d23 don't let us
down feige d23-17 this year it always is
happening this year it's January they do
it every other year usually it's ever
they're really it's not every year in
the past yeah although I was thinking
there are Disney fans who are watching
this right now you idiot how do you not
know this is probably what they're
yelling at me I don't know I was
thinking because 23 would be 100 years
of you know
Disney was founded in 1923 that's that's
why it's Club 23 and got it and the d23
Easter egg he's in a lot of things Bucky
selling Civil War you know yeah yeah
yeah that's good those are real Easter
eggs those count don't act hard I'm not
a little more okay we got a little more
we have a lot of energy thanks for being
here
I love being here
um
Mike supersonic's been watching all for
years now this is so cool imagine how I
feel in this position I feel great
I feel better
I went from a guy watching you here
to now you're here I I've been watching
you break down stuff and react to stuff
it's fun to be here you set a nice Vibe
you're a good interviewer am I yeah you
said a good tone Oh that means a lot
thank you very much
I just ask questions that's all you got
to do and sometimes you don't have to
ask questions you just got to get the
other person talking yeah and then nod
my head and go he's [__] really going
on
does associate go to your happy place
start here
I can't wait to eat
Sergio Mendoza uh hey Eric this should
be your new intro to the real rejects
welcome back to the real rejects
I just like your intro to new rockstars
okay
I think is your camera like tilted down
uh no it's straight on no no that's why
you're tilting because you're doing that
and you're going whoa and now I we moved
the camera to a different room so it's
like you're getting closer to me now oh
good but when I put my hands at the
camera my hands get huge I actually be
careful how much I just start
Dolan duck will we ever see Ant-Man
entering someone's butt it better be the
way he takes out king and Secret Wars
um that would be amazing Stephanie
Horton thank you for being here again
Stephanie she's a lovely woman you're
part of our patreon Paige too looking
forward to the Deep dive subscribe weeks
ago P.S thanks more of these fun
crossovers on both channels please well
Eric is barely a busy guy no I would
love to do this again yeah it's fun
you're in La like every you know six to
eight months well I'm gonna start being
in La more often so every time I'm here
we'll make this a weekly thing oh my God
that would be a wild thing man that'd be
crazy that would be cool we'll prepare a
real topic next time we don't need a
real topic yeah you guys dictate it
raccoon shampoo thank you again are you
guys excited for Amazon's Fallout series
I am are you do you play Fallout I'm
assuming you don't play Fallout I'm
aware of Fallout
that's good enough I'm aware of the game
and I'm aware of that Amazon's doing an
adaptation of it I will watch it I'm
excited for it I think Amazon Prime
video does some good stuff I mean the
boys Invincible rings of power rings the
power excellent you liked it that's my
big biggest regret content-wise from
2020 not covering Rings we started
covering it and then we just got too
busy yeah the rings of power gets the
fans got so mad at us and they were
right to get mad at us because we said
that we would continue covering it and I
just got too busy that is uh I loved
that show though so much it was so good
I'm glad you loved it
you didn't like it
the Dory song
you didn't cry
I can assure you I never came close to
crying
the Mordor reveal was so cool when it
said the text of Mordor
you love that
I already knew I already knew from the
geography of the I think we all did so
the Southwest what is the south of
Middle Earth of course that's where
Mordor must be they just did it like it
was a rock and roll show
I don't remember the show well enough to
even defend why I was just thought it
was fine so they just choose to love it
all right yeah that's how emotions work
uh Ben RAF what both your guys most
anticipated phase five project for me
it's been Loki season two or dirt up a
born again keep up the credit yeah those
are up there for me Loki season two
fear level born again
um I
Fantastic Four I'm pretty excited for
especially with Matt shackman directing
it yeah I am that's phase five
you know what I'm gonna give a real
cliche answer Deadpool I want I did pull
him over right yeah uh yeah I think
that's right before fantastic I gotta
say man uh yeah I feel like that move's
gonna be good that movie's Gonna Be Wild
yeah Dakota Jones hey Dakota thanks for
being here buddy Greg and the boss man
my gosh how's it going Eric hi with
Willem Dafoe now it's me and talks for
Nosferatu should he play the title role
yes even though he played him already in
Shadow of the vampire sure I didn't know
he played Nosferatu and Shadow have you
seen shadow of the vampire no oh
fantastic he's gonna yell at me what the
[__] is wrong with you the other
professional
shadow of the vampire
I think when you see Leon the
Professional there I'll start with that
should have seen me on the professional
Annie banani thank you for the moment of
silence Marcus Santos you guys are my
favorite YouTubers because I can relate
to y'all have a good day you too Marcus
that's our goal in life to be relatable
yeah we're just trying to you know give
you an excuse to be a nerd and to not
feel ashamed of it I think you're
knocking it out of the park especially
you boss boss
Scott Newman you know I called you
nicknames and then I've seen these
nicknames in the break room and I'm like
I'm pretty sure I coined these nicknames
what do you mean what nicknames lost
boss king boss oh yeah people call me
king boss yeah it was all over the break
room oh why I was told that I cannot
address you unless it was king boss who
said that I was told that I shouldn't
make eye contact with you until we were
seated in the recounters well that
that's accurate yeah I think all
monarchies are a form of evil
oh yeah I think all monarchies should be
uh outlawed by you know International
courts and I think we should go to war
with every country that is a monarchy
abolish their monarchies I think um
monarchy monarchy necessary fraternities
and sororities are evil Cults I think
you need order and to sometimes tell
people what to do
um and the way to think and feel yeah I
think religion is important to be
implemented private thought
[Laughter]
procreation I think procreation must
always be happening at a constant base
and there should be no prevention of
such a thing
loud motorcycles should be
on your lost side of the stream it's God
damn it thank you thank you we're almost
at the top here have either of you
watched the peripheral I love a
breakdown of that well he'd love a
breakdown all right I'll watch it make
those editors do 50 hours of editing
about the peripheral I love all the
suggestions I'm getting here right now
I'm adding things to my list I really
got to start with Doctor Who though
because I'm an idiot Doctor Who yeah
that'd be amazing I think you would
really enjoy it I think I would write up
your alley and Loki definitely there
were a lot of Doctor Who Vibes in here
yeah raccoon shampoo thank you again for
being here buddy is there a show where
you're like hang on why am I watching
this why am I still watching this eh
whatever I randomly started watching a
butcher competition on the History
Channel today yeah
um I don't know if I felt that way
watching a show
um
um but there I have gone down several
rabbit holes usually daily watching um
recommended videos of Gordon Ramsay and
Hell's Kitchen clips that I've seen
before and just like for whatever reason
you know the algorithm will just be like
you want some more Gordon Ramsay yelling
at this specific season of Hell's
Kitchen and I will just watch Clips
again and again I've probably seen the
same clip like a dozen times I've been
down that Wormhole way too many times
with YouTube Walking Dead was a show I
felt I had that conscious decision
season yeah and I was like I know what
you're doing it was around season eight
yeah I definitely lost interest in that
show I mean we stopped covering it
um that was the first show I've ever
actively been like
I'm quitting a bummer because it was so
good it was so it was good for a while
yeah and I don't know well it became
this I've heard it got great again at
some point right I think there were some
great some great episodes that came back
but at that point I just would have to
start watching again
we're almost there Eric Jesse Grotto
Brody's much love to both y'all both
channels are really great and I love you
all are some great people love The Vibes
and keep up the great work best collab
ever amazing what a lot of love and
praise right there I love that yeah they
are thanks man they should be all the
super chats what's with this like hey
Eric what do you think about Facebook no
that's okay I appreciate the question I
say no just price
thank you thank you raccoon shampoo huh
my four man didn't quite work there it
did we read it but I appreciate it the
additional Super Chat to clarify that
buddy
um Jay swizzy thank you for the Super
Chat possible Fantastic Four Doom drop
in quantumania there's a lot of rumors
about that thoughts of us I think we do
this every every title we're like Doom
in this one I'm just looking for in this
one dude I'm gonna take over for
Chadwick black panther yeah I think the
only reference we'll get is a connection
through like King's family it's the
Richards Dynasty though the uh but I
think other than that I don't well it's
like crazy because one division had a
total like they was one division or Loki
it was Loki Loki had the Fantastic Four
ship right the director came out and
said like that's the Fantastic Four ship
what yeah yeah it was Loki what yeah
this right guys am I right about that
what guys in the chat we still have the
chat going by the way I see it so I just
want to make sure like they said that it
was Loki right that where they had the
ship that appeared at one point you
don't remember this I think you pointed
it the collector's ship appeared it's a
collector ship it was Infinity War four
ships yeah I was gonna say damn
it's okay I'm sorry no
no where's John he's at home with his
family right now
he's having a good day let's get him in
here John
take the chainsaw he's at home
yes you're right I mean it's puppet show
who's he's right
no I'm right you need to clarify if I
write or you're right I'm for sure right
about that I did make a video about it
but you know I don't know you haven't
seen the professional uh
Eric Marco Santos do you know what my
hero Academia is do you
um
I can't claim to be an expert in my hero
Academia have you seen it no oh my God
it's a phenomenal show phenomenal it's
recommended to me all the time it's like
X-Men on crack it's amazing okay it's
like if people accepted that there were
mutants in the world it's amazing okay a
lot of you are probably surprised at
like there's a lot of titles that have
come through here and they're just
surprised that I haven't seen it well
that's it's because I've seen all these
other things that I have made videos
about so many freaking times Well you
make the best piece of content for you
because that's the thing and still spend
hours like sometimes 10 hours writing
scripts because so you know he'll watch
one episode of time to binge other ones
yeah so Eric's just asking you kindly to
get off his back no everyone get on my
back saying like everyone hit my back
too much and it's it's incessant how you
guys behave your Fanboy over here it's a
just be who you are it's fine I'm not
gonna police any kind of fandom you guys
need to back
I am a a fandom libertarian We're Not
Gonna police it
Alex Wolf from hereditary yeah a big fan
of you good to see you here buddy I like
it it's a great work Alex I can see
everything tez dispense um Neo uh what
if we saw a Green Lantern variant of
Deadpool what I I think uh that would be
oh fascinating like like a Deadpool is
is Green Lantern I don't understand the
question but I would love that John's in
the chat right here he's been listening
this whole time oh my God thank you
Johnny wow John we're literally ending
the stream related relatively soon
I'm not telling everyone to [__] off I'm
saying that you got that Eric is asking
for some some distance here no I no and
uh no don't give me any distance
you see him in the street don't say
here's what I want for I want I want my
followers to give me the equivalent of
that um of that Runner or I think it was
a stalker no it wasn't a clicker yet who
plants that tendril kiss uh that's a
stalker yeah yeah because he wasn't a
full
he didn't have the full bloom yet yes
but he did have half it I think that's a
stalker yeah Runner stalker clickers the
show hasn't distinguished between
stalkers and Runners yeah yeah because
the show's [__] lazy
[Laughter]
laughs
just keep it keep it alive here
now Lieutenant LT special Lieutenant LT
Smith
Neil Gaiman should write something in
the MCU the most ethereal thing you
should have written eternals
um
that is good that is a good call the
furpos did a good job with that script
they did
I know you liked it that was the first
that's when I met you eternals that's
right that's not the first time yeah and
I and I vehemently disagreed with you
about it you kept your mouth shut I was
like maybe Eric's on the same page as me
I said maybe I said it's interesting I
turn your goddamn video and I'm like
what the [__] he's crazy this [__] we
had such a difference you didn't he
didn't yes anime at all up there he just
didn't say anything in response silent
um Jackie Almas thank you for being uh
in the moment of silence Connie's saying
we know Connie she's a friend hey Connie
what a nice dream to come home to after
a long day of work I said fat random
fact I sent JBL to new rockstars group
JBL like uh headphones yeah and stuff
that she sent that to you and poor
Zach's car got broken into so I resent
all the product I'm sorry I still use uh
the JBL headphones thank you for sending
those Connie uh I think many of our
teams still uses some jbl's Zach was
wearing a real rejects uh jacket uh
today yeah which made me very happy and
nothing else nothing else long hanging
out at all that's what he called Zach
schlong raccoon shampoo final question
from me what Eric wants more from you
what's your favorite decoration in the
background right now oh that's a good
question
um
hmm oh my god did the funkos count as
decoration sure why not
um none of those
um
I really like this uh Heisenberg yeah
it's awesome yeah that's pretty cool
um this this was made for patrons it was
uh John and Greg is the hall you can't
see it it's with cameras not Auto
focusing if I can turn that auto focus
on right let's get my face camera
[Music]
right there
there I hopefully you guys caught the
photo
um let's see here that's great what
sometimes if you read the chat at the
same time your mind goes a little bit
crazy it's Associated the cats are
getting rowdy I know I know they want my
attention
come on come here we'll play I love you
he said [__] off
that's why I love cats they're so
aggressive I love you yeah you're a DJ
turntable aren't you I love you
I love you love me he's like I don't
know who you are
um yeah I'll say that one raccoon Rupert
Jamison rrr deserves more awareness
movie of the year in my opinion I need
to watch that and I want to break it
down I am shocked it was not nominated
even if you want to check it out I am
shocked it was a nominated shocked
utterly shocked I think you'd really
like it it's a fun movie yeah it's long
it's fun it's like three hours I'm okay
with it being long you like long stuff
that could be a innuendo exactly are you
in the chat
hi guys
that's that's how he so that's how he
pitched me when we said we should
collect do you got any long thin stuff
Alexander vestabek hi guys how are you
hi Alexander we're good I'm good Eric's
hanging in there hey I'm getting I'm
just warming up yeah I could do this
all day uh Dick Tracy Eric Voss is the
homelander of YouTube I don't know if
Nick Tracy is a big fan of me pick
Tracy's posted like Dick Tracy is the
one who said that I faked my reactions
and I think that's I think you're
calling me a sociopathic Tracy yeah I've
gotta so I I don't think I've taken some
tests not a sociopath I do have some
probably some disorders
but um you got a narcissistic
personality disorder is what you're
telling me I I'm not uh homicidal I've
never wanted to I've never fantasized
about lasering a crowd of people oh
well I thought we had something in
common there for a second Eric
what that means
well that means that one of us just has
bigger Ambitions in life
okay
let's keep going no
exactly has said this just because Dick
Tracy gave you two bucks to be mean to
me I've had way worse than this chat
about me I'm like you're a weird guy to
keep setting five dollars just keep
insulting me
is episode three the best one yet you
should you have you get way more
comments on a daily basis you should be
like yeah I just watched it today it's
it's very emotional I mean
I really liked episode one of that show
a lot
um but yeah of the three that I've seen
I think episode three is my favorite I
don't know if it'll be everyone's
favorite but it was my favorite
uh I think what's in it will cause a
debate you've seen it yeah yeah I think
it'll cause a debate too but not like an
insane debate but a debate it'll cause a
debate I think it will yeah Josh pivito
Eric playing Greg Street management
no it's okay Josh pavito I don't know
what that is but they're surprised over
here that's good to hear
Eric
we did it Quentin Randell moment of
silence thank you last question here we
go samil badenfeld Eric we're gonna make
this question count okay Eric any chance
you
apostrophe L cover any video game
stories on the Deep dive Eric the
Spider-Man game has a really good
Spider-Man story Eric the evolution of
Modoc and the Avengers game is really
unique
yes there is a chance that I might be
doing a video game content because
here's the deal I'm calling it The Deep
dive and we're not going to limit
ourselves just to movies
um sure at the start it'll be a movie
analysis Channel but over time I'd love
to expand that out to cover all kinds of
things video games graphic novels
documentaries documentaries music videos
TV episodes like I would love to do a
deep dive just of the uh the dinner
party episode of The Office what about
televised Christian sermons oh yeah are
you talking about the ones where they do
like parodies of like Marvel movies and
uh and like I'm just talking about pure
like Joyce Meyers
no there is a I can't remember the name
of it uh but there's a really really
funny Creator who just kind of reviews
things it's just so matter of fact and
she's not like mean about it but she she
did like a reaction that's like an hour
and a half long to every year there's
some church in Canada that does like
Easter uh performances no way do the
Christ crucifixion story The
Resurrection story but like do it in the
style of Star Trek and they do like
parody songs oh that's sacrilege they
hey they're giving it they're all over
the years some of their jokes haven't
aged very well but these performers are
really really trying hard and she made a
video reacting to it I I gotta find it I
wish I could remember the name of the
Creator someone in the comments may know
we'll see I'll try to worry but she's so
great guys look we we peaked at like 17
to 1800 uh viewers holy smokes and then
now we were ending it with 11
[Laughter]
holy smokes guys this was a good stream
we uh I think did you did you enjoy your
time here I had a blast this was great
are you tired no you don't have to lie
let's keep going
open up
I will let you go to the bathroom don't
you fret guys thank you so much for
being here thinking hey everyone be in
the chat thank you one last request if
you guys can just leave a like that
would be very much appreciated 11
million people here we broke the
internet
um this was fun and unexpected and
spontaneous
fine thank you guys so much thank you
John uh Josh best friend I have John's
friend that's wherever people are like
you're John's friend aren't you
that's me that's what my family calls me
and uh Eric check out his channel the
Deep dive when does that premiere
February 17th we're gonna have five
videos launching the more date of
February 17th so a lot of videos
everything
Loki live stream breakdown of guanamania
and then an interesting investigation of
how trailers are lying to us you won't
be able to watch anything else that day
because it's not like a major Marvel
movie is coming out that day what the
[__] was I think gonna be no competition
for anyone damn it why did I pick that
thing just no one else gonna have Man
videos going up
on that note thank you Eric for being
here thank you guys for having me thank
you guys for hanging out with us and uh
I'm gonna have fun I'm going to
officially end the stream now oh nope I
need that thing to end the stream yep
get it back up and we will talk with you